Guten Morgen Tim. Bin gerade aufgewacht, sag mal wie steht's eigentlich in diesem Wahlkampf? Äh Wahlkampf ist ja nicht schon vorbei.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zwo zwo neun euer Gegenmittel gegen langweilige Wahlkämpfe und andere politische Debatten, die.
Der Wahlkampf ist zwar nicht langweilig, das ist nur Unverschämtheit, ich fordere ein neues Wahlkampfduell, sonst gehe ich.
Linus äh Podcast.
Meine Güte.
Ja, ist wirklich, also ich meine, dass das Wahlkampf in Deutschland langweilig ist, ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade so eine Neuigkeit, ne.
Äh wie heißt der denn langweilig?
Ist irgendwas spannend gerade.
Gamescom, YouTube-Interviews. Also ich, also wird doch auf eine Weise irgendwie auch zelebriert wie noch nie zuvor. Weil es geht irgendwie um nichts, ne.
Also inhaltlich findet er ja nicht wirklich statt. Kommen wir gleich nochmal zu.
Gleich nochmal zu. Aber äh wir finden inhaltlich noch statt.
Wir finden inhaltlich statt und wir.
Hat sich ja auch gerade an der letzten Woche wieder mal gezeigt.
Für genau wäre.
Das größte Sommercomeback eines Podcast ever.
Wenigstens hatten wir eine Entschuldigung.
Feedback zur letzten Sendung. Ähm.
Michael frag, was spreche dagegen, wenn ihr selbst eine Wahlsoftware schreibt, die meinetwegen als freie Software für alle zugänglich macht und dem BSI gebt
Die hätte ja diese Menge bestimmt nicht nebenbei müssen diese Softwareleute bedienen können
so was wie freiwillige Helfer sind. Ja äh genau, warum machen wir es eigentlich nicht? Ähm.
Also kurzer Hintergrund für die Leute, die vielleicht letzte Woche noch nicht zugeschaltet hatten und äh unter eurem Stein plagen. Ja, also äh wir hatten
ein Spezial zum Thema Wahl, Software, weil du und andere äh halt diese Auszählungssoftware auseinandergenommen haben,
ja und das gab eine Menge ich unter anderem dieses so und was wäre jetzt wenn wenn du alles neu schreiben würdest? Wäre das gut.
Wenn ich alles neu schreiben würde, wäre das äh wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt gut, weil ich bin kein guter Programmierer, ähm deswegen finde ich ja auch so so leicht die Fehler andere, weil ich mir einfach vorstelle, wie.
Nice tats.
Wie du das verkacken wir das so.
Nein, denkst halt einfach so über das Problem nach und denkst so, boah wo muss ich das erste Mal drüber nachdenken und da fängst du an zu bohren. Aber.
Security Szene ist auch krass, ne? Man muss eigentlich nichts gönnen, man muss nur gut sein und kaputt machen. So.
Und das finde ich auch, deswegen habe ich dieses Feedback auch rausgenommen, weil das natürlich eine ähm eine Kritik ist, die der diese Security-Szene.
Ausgesetzt ist immer mal wieder ähm.
Das ist im Prinzip andere schaffen etwas, ne? Und wenn die fertig sind äh kommen diese äh Security-Leute blicken auf wenige Zeilen von zehn oder hunderttausenden und sagen falsch.
Deine Sandburg das war ja alles auf Sand gebaut genau.
Genau. Ähm das ist mitunter richtig ähm.
Dass da teilweise zu hemisch,
über über Dinge geredet wird und dass man sich eben auch überlegen kann, ne, wenn das alles so, also gerade im so im Linux-Bereich oder so, hörst du da mal so eine so ein ähm Punkt, wenn ihr das doch alles so viel besser könnt, ne? Dann helft doch bitte mit,
und und helft uns helft uns in dieser Open Source Software, ähm, dass es eben besser funktioniert und wartet nicht bis ihr unsere Fehler findet und euch dann damit brüsten könnt, ja? Das finde ich ein validen, einen validen Kritikpunkt.
Gleichzeitig ist aber, was spreche dagegen, wenn ihr selbst eine Wahlsoftware schreibt, zeigt er auch irgendwie so ein bisschen den Anspruch, den offenbar Menschen an,
an andere hegen ähm,
Irgendwie macht sich ja wohl keiner darüber Gedanken, wie ich meine Miete bezahle, ne? Also, ich soll das jetzt kostenlos äh liefern. Es gibt einfach keine Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten dafür und das ist übrigens auch die entscheidende,
Forderung in der Pressemitteilung des Chaos-Computerclubs, wo wir viele Forderungen aufstellen, unter anderem geht doch bitte hin, schreibt sowas aus mit der Anforderung Open Source zu sein und dann selbstverständlich arbeiten wir dann da auch mit
ja und äh was weiß ich, setzen, dass man Samstag hin und machen Patches und dann kommt da auch nicht so ein Desaster bei raus. Ähm dass wir so ein Theater äh um eine Veröffentlichung machen müssen. Dieses Mal mussten wir dieses Theater machen, weil
insbesondere hier in Deutschland. Seit einem Jahr alle davon reden,
dass der der Russe die Wahl heckt, ne, der Ivan, der kommt und äh will äh der hat Social Bots und der hat äh Fake News und der hat Hacker, ne?
Offenbar kümmert sich keine Sau darum und auch das meine lieben Freunde haben wir übrigens äh vollständig kostenlos gemacht. Ich wurde vom vom guten Freund dann auch irgendwann also wirklich Tage später gefragt so, sag mal, wer hat den, wer hat das eigentlich bezahlt,
Ja, niemand hat das bezahlt. Das haben wir in unserer Freizeit am Wochenende gemacht,
Ne? Also äh es ist noch nicht mal das Geld dafür da, dass wir uns den Schrott, der existiert anschauen. Ähm jetzt hat auch noch und es ist auch kein Geld dafür da, dass wir ordentlich ordentlichen Schrott bauen.
Ja, vor allem, das wäre ja auch.
Ähm, das ist ja genau das, was wir kritisieren.
Wäre auch vor allem die Verantwortung dieser Firma gewesen, äh zumindest mal so ein Security-Ordited mal äh zu machen. Ich meine, das haben sie ja noch nicht mal getan.
Wir reden ja wir reden ja jetzt noch nicht mal gleich von Open Source, aber wenn man überhaupt so was produziert,
vielleicht mal jemanden externes ranholen, der da mal ein Wochenende drüber schaut, dann wäre wahrscheinlich von von all dem, was ihr da rausgefunden habt, schon herzlich wenig übrig geblieben, weil das findet einfach mal jeder sofort.
Genau und wenn du wenn du da jemanden bestellst, der,
den dafür bezahlst, dann kriegst du den gleichen Rat wie von uns, ist übrigens etwas, wo ich sehr viel Wert drauf gelegt habe, dass wir einen ordentlichen Outlet-Bericht abgelegt haben. Ja, da da ist viele Arbeit drin, größtenteils ähm.
Ja, er einfach ärgerliche Arbeit, ja? Dokumentation genau erklären, wo das Problem liegt, genaue Empfehlungen zur Behebung geben. Wer,
sag ich mal uns damit beauftragt, hätte hätte nichts anderes bekommen als diesen Bericht. Hätte halt nicht diese Pressemitteilung dazu bekommen. Ähm,
da wird's dann eben, dass es eben der Teil, den du kriegst, wenn du so etwas über Jahrzehnte sträflich vernachlässigst.
Genau. Das hätte dann auch ein paar tausend Euro gekostet sicherlich die ganze Aktion, aber das werden wir sicherlich noch billiger gewesen als dieser äh Totalschaden in der Öffentlichkeit.
Genau, das wäre, das hätte man billiger kriegen können und wäre für uns alle besser gewesen, insofern äh lachen wir da ja vor allem über,
wir lachen ja noch nicht mal, wir wir weinen ja mit äh über diese diese Versäumnisse und diese dieser Dilettantismus, mit dem da gearbeitet wird
Norman kommentiert, ich danke für euer Engagement und die unschätzbar wichtige Arbeit mit dieser Software. Mich stört ein wenig die Stammtischähnliche Häme, mit der über die Verfehlung des Herstellers, beziehungsweise des Entwicklers hergezogen wird. Andererseits ist die Fassung, angesichts dieser Sicherheitslücken tatsächlich
kaum zu wahren. Ja, genauso würde ich das auch sehen. Ähm niemand kreidet hier einem einzelnen Entwicklerfehler an.
Ne? Es geht eher darum ähm dass wie fahrlässig hier vorgegangen wird und dass sich,
auch heute noch wie wir an äh wie wir sehen ähm geweigert wird den Rat,
andere anzunehmen und der Rat, den wir da geben, ist auch nur der Rat anderer, das nennt man best Practices, ja? Also,
Man weiß eben, wie man Dinge macht. Das ist das ist Wissen, was in der Zukunft
und an der Uni tradiert wird und ähm auf diesem Wissen sollten wir aufbauen, um Fehler nicht immer neu selbst zu machen. Und ich, das sage ich als jemand, der,
ganz besonders stark an dem Nordinvente, hier Sindrom leidet und auch immer alles selber programmieren möchte und äh dann immer mal wieder in das kalte Wasser springt, äh sich mit den Frameworks und Librarys anderer auseinanderzusetzen und zu sehen, wie schön und elegant viele Personen vor mir, Probleme,
gelöst haben und ich nun als Programmierer auf deren Schultern stehen kann.
Man bildet ja auch mal viel über so ein lebenslanges äh Lernen und nirgendswo ist eigentlich fortwährend Weiterbildung so wichtig wie im Softwarebereich, weil sich das, weil das einfach eines der Bereiche ist, die sich einfach am schnellsten bewegen. Also da hat,
ist ja nach zehn Jahren kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen.
Richtig und also ich war zum Beispiel echt überrascht, ähm als ich das, weil,
versuche das jetzt mal ohne Namenssendung. Also ich habe einen äh Hardware Security-Training äh absolviert bei einem bekannten Hardwarehacker. Ähm.
Und dort war ein äh war ein eine bekannte Größe der IT-Security Szene unter den Besuchern. Jemand, der quasi schon, also der in sehr,
ein sehr alten Ruf hat und ich war ich habe äh so spontan gesagt, Mensch krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich dich hier noch bei so einem Training sehe, ne? Und er sagte auch so, ja selbstverständlich, so meinst du, meinst du, ich habe ich kann jetzt irgendwie einfach sagen, ich höre jetzt auf,
Und jetzt lehre ich nur noch oder arbeite nur noch bei den bei den großen Unternehmen
und und lerne nix mehr dazu, ganz im Gegenteil äh muss auch ich zusehen, dass ich am Ball bleibe, ne. Das war,
in dem Fall 'ne schöne glaub ich auch 'ne große Freude halt für,
für Demetrie, der das der das Training da angeboten hat. Jetzt wissen die Eingeweihten, um wen es sich handelt, aber nicht um den Besucher. Ich glaube, dessen Privatsphäre wollte ich weniger verletzen. Ähm,
Also man muss man muss immer weiter lernen und wenn man dann, wenn sich jemand quasi deswissen, was ein Allgemeinwissen ist äh verweigert und sich dagegen sperrt und die Sachen falsch macht, dann kann man muss man da eben auch mal drüber lachen dürfen,
Ähm und dann kommt direkt daran angeknüpft inhaltlich TM, gibt es neben der technischen auch eine finanzielle Analyse. Was hat der Haufen Schrott denn gekostet? Ich bin froh, diese Antwort nicht geben zu müssen, denn das macht die Antwort gibt,
Johnny.
Welcher Schrott die Software dieser PC-Wahlsoftware.
Äh Johnny, ich hatte zwischendurch ein bisschen Mitleid mit dem Entwickler, wenn man bedenkt, wie lange es die Software schon gibt, kann man ja ungefähr auf das Alter zurückschließen. Ja, wie gesagt, ist keine Entschuldigung dafür,
nichts zu können, ganz im Gegenteil, er hatte ein Leben lang Zeit, das zu lernen
Dann habe ich aber irgendwo gelesen, dass die Firma da mit circa eine halbe Million Euro Umsatz im Jahr macht
Da war das Mitleid ganz schnell wieder weg. Ähm jetzt wäre es neben den technischen Vorgängen auch mal interessant, die organisatorischen Vorgänge aufzuzeigen, wie kann also jemand allein und ohne Aufsicht dorthin kommen,
unter über Jahre bleiben. Ja, das stimmt, also dieser Umsatzangabe stimmt grob und ähm.
Ist auch ja bekannt, dass dieses Unternehmen, also die Firma.
Berninger Software, die die Software PC Wahl macht, wurde mit Wirkung vom ersten ersten zweitausendsechzehn an die Konkurrenz verkauft
Äh die Unterlagen dazu sind öffentlich für zwei Komma sechs Millionen
Und dieser Entwickler, ja, der also jetzt äh am ersten ersten zwanzig sechzehn diese Software für zwei Komma sechs Millionen an die Konkurrenz verkauft hat, ne? Der ist doch an dem Tag unserer Veröffentlichung vor Lachen nicht in den Schlaf gekommen.
Also bin ich mir ganz sicher, der ist vor Lachen nicht in den Schlaf gekommen,
Ähm Steinchen fragt dann noch, warum bedarf es einer lokal installierten Anwendung für die Datei Dateneingabe von doch einer,
eher sehr übersichtlichen Anschau an wer äh Anzahl an Werten, die anschließend per Internet übertragen werden. Wäre eine Webanwendung auf Landes- oder Bundesservern nicht einfacher. Ähm,
ist auf jeden Fall eine Überlegung wert. Entscheidend ist ähm,
dass dann natürlich ganz andere Sicherheitsanforderungen gelten würden, weil im Moment ist ja der Kern, sagen sie mal, ja das läuft bei uns in den abgesicherten Nestnetzen, da kommt niemand rein. Wenn du jetzt was bauen möchtest und das ans Internet hängst, ne, dann bist du wirklich sich jemand damit auseinandersetzen
der sich auskennt und du müsstest dann, dass dieses Modell noch mit einem Vertrauensanker.
Versehen, der wirklich sicherstellt, dass nur autorisierte Personen da Daten eingeben können, dass die Daten, die sie eingeben, signiert werden müssen und dass ähm.
Dass du,
quasi jegliche Angriffe auf dieses System in irgendeiner Weise verhinderst. Also das wäre dann der der Punkt du zentralisierst und schaffst Oberfläche, dann musst du aber auf jeden Fall eine ganz klare Vertrauenskette bauen.
Würde aber keine Ahnung, mir würden auch Ideen einfallen, ne? Also wenn solange diese Ergebnisse signiert sind, kannst du eh alles irgendwie auf,
den verrücktesten Wegen sie übertragen, denn sie sind ja nicht geheim.
Ja, ich denke, man muss da jetzt an der Stelle auch ein paar Sachen äh trennen, also ob jetzt Daten von einem,
von einer App quasi übers Internet übertragen werden oder ob diese App sich in einem Webbrowser befindet, ist dann so für die Übertragung erstmal
relativ relevant, andererseits, wenn du Web machst, heißt ja auch noch nicht unbedingt, dass das Web im Internet stattfindet, das kann ja dann immer noch ein geschlossenes äh Netzwerk sein
Ja, also das ist dann eher eine Frage, wie ist die Infrastruktur über die
die Daten übertragen werden, ist das ein Public Internetzugang, der da genutzt wird oder muss man sich von vornherein schon in einem geschlossenen Netzwerk
befinden, aber das ist dann wiederum vollkommen unabhängig von der Frage, ist das jetzt eine Software auf Windows oder ist das äh eine Webgeschichte, aber dann muss halt auch die Rechner wiederum anders sichern und
nochmal ganz andere, ja.
Also du hast du, du hast einfach ein ganz anderes ähm ein ganz anderes Stread-Model und man kann, man kann alles machen,
die der Punkt ist, sich dabei über die Risiken,
im Klaren zu sein, welche Angriffsoberflächen man hat und gegen welche Angriffsoberfläche man etwas tun muss. Und prinzipiell ist es ja erstmal,
das Ärgerliche immer bei der Zentralisierung, dass man sich eben eine zentrale Angriffsfläche baut, ja? Ähm insofern eine Webseite, wo alle wissen, da geht's hin. Ähm,
würde eben auch unter Umständen zentral, wenn du dann da einen Fehler machst, dann kannst du halt alle Stimmen manipulieren, ne? Also da sind immer, sind immer Modelle abzuwägen, insofern gibt es da,
architektonisch gar keine gar nichts, was man unbedingt präferieren müsste. Ähm entscheidend ist sich,
im Klaren darüber zu sein, wo die Vertrauensanker sind,
Ähm, ich habe da am äh an einem historischen Datum den sechsunddreißigsten Geburtstag des Chaos-Computerclubs auch noch einen kleinen Datengarten zu abgehalten im im CC Berlin,
wo ich nochmal so ein bisschen mit Folien und so ein bisschen das erklärt habe. Ah so viel zur letzten Sendung.
Parallel zu Apple Keynote. Alternative Keynote sozusagen.
Ja, eine Keynote mit Neuigkeiten.
Wo war was, wo waren wir? Ja, also tut mir leid.
So von von Netzpolitik Ork gibt's äh The Daily League. Nein, andere Meister hat äh ein bisschen länger daran gearbeitet, hat er mir gestern erzählt.
Und zwar hat er sich ähm hat er äh untersucht, wie sich der BND mit dem,
Mit dem Anonymisierungsdienst, neben einer Tor auseinandergesetzt hat. Ich,
Erklär doch mal, ich glaube, ich hab's hier in der Sendung schon öfter mal erklärt, aber ich erkläre nochmal ganz kurz Thor. Ähm.
Willst du das machen oder soll ich irgendwie das vielleicht mal in Ordnung? Ja.
Erklär mal in deinen Worten.
Also Tor äh versucht eine Lösung dafür äh zu schaffen, dass man äh mehr oder weniger unerkannt äh über das Internet kommunizieren kann, primär halt äh auf das Web zugreifen kann. Und nutzt dafür,
Daher kommt auch dieser Begriff Tor ähm wie Onian, Roater, so eine zwiebelartiges Durchleiten der Daten.
Und in diesem Netzwerk, was quasi oft das normale Internet draufgesetzt wird, hast du halt solche Knoten, die eben diese Verteilung machen und Endpunkte, wo die Daten äh in dieses Netz hinein geraten und auch wieder herausgeraten,
und die Daten werden dann halt in verschiedenen Zwiebelschichten so eingepackt und dann auch wieder ausgepackt,
sodass äh wenn sie dann halt an einer Stelle aus diesem Netz wieder heraustreten, man nicht mehr wissen kann,
woher sie kommen, da bekommt sehr viel Verschlüsselung zum Einsatz und das ist halt seit Jahren eigentlich so, dass Gott Netzwerk um eben,
möglichst unerkannt zu bleiben, wenn man halt surft, weil sonst wäre halt die eigene IP-Adresse direkt sichtbar. Das lässt unmittelbare Schlüsse äh zu und das wird dann halt,
verhindert.
Man kann sich das wie so ein digitales Hütchenspiel,
vorstellen, ne? Du willst dein Paket, dein deine Anfrage geht in dieses Tornetzwerk rein, wird da ein paar Mal hin und her geschoben und kommt dann an anderer Stelle wieder raus, ja? Das heißt, es gibt zwar jemanden,
Am Eingang des Tornetzwerkes, der weiß, wer du bist.
Und es gibt jemanden am Ausgang des Tornetzwerkes, der weiß, mit wem du kommunizierst. Und in der Mitte gibt es
Instanzen, die wissen beides nicht, sondern schieben einfach nur hin und her. Und deswegen gibt es am Ende keine einzelne Instanz, die weiß, wer du bist und wer die andere Partei ist, mit der du kommunizierst.
Klingt erstmal einfach, aber dann so über die Jahre auch so ihre äh Schwachstellen gehabt, weil man sich natürlich auch durch andere Eigenschaften verraten kann.
Ja, zum Beispiel, dass du dich bei Facebook einloggst.
Ja, genau, also ich meine, wenn du dich dann halt direkt sozusagen zu erkennen gibst, aber auch da, ja, äh kann man dann zumindest erstmal gegenüber Facebook verschleiern, woher man kommt. Das ist ja dann sozusagen auch schon mal ein Gewinn.
Abschließend kann man, glaube ich, über Tor sagen es ist bei weitem nicht perfekt, aber es ist bisher immer noch das Beste, was wir haben und ähm.
Wurde irgendwie dann also um den Use Case, man kommt aus dem Tornetz wieder raus und verschleiert quasi seine Identität im,
Tatsächlich im Internet da draußen,
Ergänzt um die Funktion auch einfach Sachen im Tornetzwerk drin zu lassen. Also ich kann quasi einen Dienst im Tornetzwerk anbieten.
Und so quasi auch meinen Server selber verstecken. Also nicht nur als Client kann ich das für meine Anonymisierung nutzen, sondern auch als Server. Und das ist dann das, was äh immer als Darknet.
Genau, wobei dieses
Darknet, das muss man ja dann gleich betonen, das ist halt wie wie immer absolut äh Doul-Use Technologie, ja, es kann halt einen Informationsserver sein für,
Rechtler und Widerständler in repressiven Regimen, aber es kann halt auch irgendwie der Drogenumschlagumschlagplatz sein, der versucht, seine äh Identität und seinen Ort äh zu verschleiern
beides ist leider halt möglich, weil man kriegt das eine kaum ohne das andere. Das ist halt äh so. Äh dementsprechend gibt's verschiedenste Interessen der Geheimdienste dem habhaft zu werden, sowohl der Bürgerrechtler, als auch der.
Kriminellen.
Richtig. Also Angriffe und Verteidigung gelten eben immer für alle und stehen gerade im Bereich der Software Eilen zur Verfügung.
Und da muss man sich eben äh überlegen, was man als Gesellschaft haben möchte, ne? Man sagt, okay, wir,
wollen chinesischen Disidenten die Möglichkeit geben, überhaupt noch irgendwie zu kommunizieren. Hm,
und zu veröffentlichen und Meinungen zu äußern und wir nehmen dafür in Kauf, dass,
Wir Technologien bauen, die eben auch in anderen Regionen, die weit frei, weitaus freier sind,
eben dann von anderen Leuten genutzt werden, die sich verstecken müssen, wo oder verstecken wollen, wozu eben auch Kriminelle gehören. Ich habe aber auch seit Ewigkeiten so ein Projekt liegen, Logbuch Netzpolitik äh als als Onian
Service anzubieten.
Aber ich muss da noch so, also ich äh sitze der hängt halb rum. Ich habe mir sogar schon den Onni einen Kiegel Brutforst. So mit Logbuch Venety. Und so, ja, ja klar.
Wow.
Ja, ja, muss da noch ähm hoffentlich habe ich den überhaupt noch. Nee, aber ich muss noch die Confix schreiben, die die äh die die Inhalte umschreibt. Aber okay,
Dieses Netzwerktor vielen von euch ohnehin bekannt.
Hat natürlich die Geheimdienste auch seit jeher beschäftigt. Einiges davon wissen wir aus dem
NSA Untersuchungsausschuss aus den's neuen Veröffentlichungen. Interessanterweise fängt zweitausendsieben der BND schon an und sagt, schaut sich diese Idee von Tor an und hat,
grundgesetzliche Überlegungen, wie man dieses Netz integrieren kann. Und darüber spricht der BND zweitausendacht schon mit den USA und den Vereinigten Königreich und ähm.
Da hält die Abteilung TA ähm,
einen Vortrag mit dem Titel, eine das das Anonymisierungsnetzwerktor und eine mögliche Auflösung der Anonymisierungsfunktion.
Die Abteilung TA ist die Abteilung technischer Aufklärung. Im Prinzip so der der Haupt man könnte sagen einer der Hauptdarsteller im NSA-Untersuchungs,
Ausschuss. Ähm nach der ja auch der Podcast technische Aufklärung benannt wurde.
Und äh die sind also jetzt seit zweitausendacht in einer Kooperation äh mit den USA und dem Vereinigten Königreich daran Tor äh anzugreifen.
Es gibt relativ wenig Informationen, wie sie es genau machen mit welcher Technik. Aber das Entscheidende ist, dass,
das Design-Dokument von Thor ähm von Roger Dingeldein verfasst, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Schon sagt, dass es sich hierbei ähm um eine,
um ein Verteidigungsmodell unter der Annahme handelt, dass es keinen globalen Adverssery gibt, also kein,
globalen Überwacher, der das gesamte Internet sieht. Ähm deswegen schubst du quasi auch deine Datenpakete in diesem Tornetzwerk durch verschiedene,
Länder und Juristiken in der Annahme.
Dass irgendwo einer dabei ist, wo man die Kette nicht schließen kann.
Dass du irgendwo die Kette unterbrichst, ja? Also würdest du Tor, würdest du ein Deutschlandtor bauen,
Ja, dann wäre im Zweifelsfall alles
unter der Fuchtel eines zentralen Überwachungspunktes äh in Frankfurt, von dem wir ja jetzt Kenntnis haben äh und und an anderen Knotenpunkten in Deutschland und du hättest keine dein Modell würde nicht funktionieren, weil du davon ausgehen musst, dass es einen globalen Überwacher gibt, der jede,
der jeder einzelne Datenübertragung innerhalb deines kleinen Tornetzwerkes ebenfalls sieht. Und äh deswegen wird hier so eine
Geheimdienst, Zusammenarbeit
Man könnte sagen notwendig oder brisant, weil sie dadurch sich natürlich quasi Coverage verschaffen, ne? Und je mehr Geheimdienste zusammenarbeiten, umso eher können sie sich zu einem Global Advers Harry zusammenschließen und das gesamte Tornetzwerk.
Überwachen.
Ist das nicht toll Netzwerk eigentlich in in der Hinsicht irgendwie getunt, dass man mehr oder weniger garantiert immer mehrere inkompatible Juristiken äh überschreitet.
Circles werden danach optimiert, dass du das, dass die, dass dir das nicht passiert.
Also immer möglichst viel Feinde äh zusammenbinden sozusagen die sich so schnell nicht einig werden können und dann äh funktioniert's besser.
Also du es wird das Netzwerk ist stets bemüht, ne? Ähm.
Aber so klassische also klassische Angriffs Optionen, die einen da natürlich schon in Sinn kommt ist, wenn du,
den Zielpunkt weißt, ja? Ähm! Dann kannst du quasi gucken, wo wo
in der Menge Daten reingehen, ne? Es gibt viele Enterypunkte, es gibt viele Exit-Punkte und dann gibt's von mir aus einen Zielpunkt und jetzt wäre das einfachste, du zählst einfach die Pakete, ne? Wer schickt Pakete ins Tornetzwerk rein? In der Menge, wie sie an meinem Zielpunkt reinkommen,
ankommen, ja? Also anfangen, du du benutzt da du siehst das Tornetzwerk als als äh Blackbox, siehst aber die ganzen und guckst an deinem, guckst an
Im Zielpunkt, ob es da ankommt, also quasi verschiedene Möglichkeiten der Traffic-Korrelation, ja ähm wären da.
Eine eine theoretische Angriffsmöglichkeit schon. Ähm eine andere, du baust Verzögerungen ein, ja? Also das ist per meine persönliche Theorie, wie ähm,
Wiesohinservices gesucht werden, dass du einfach Unterbrechungen an verschiedenen Stellen im globalen Internet,
einfügst, immer ganz kurz und dadurch irgendwann ein Bild hast,
wie der Traffic, den du zu diesem Hidden Service hast, unterbrochen wird und dann irgendwann eingrenzen kannst, in welchem, auf welchem Kontinent das Ding steht und dann in welchem Land und dann in welchem Rechenzentrum. Das wäre so meine vorsichtige Theorie, wie sie's machen.
Alle diese Eingriffsmöglichkeiten äh sind aber auch öffentlich dokumentiert, denn die es gibt eine ausführliche Forschung zu diesem Tor. Nur so kommt es eben weiter, denn auch Tor ist Open Source Software und auch hier gibt es viele Forscher, die Angriffs äh
Mechanismen äh untersuchen, dokumentieren,
veröffentlichen und dann eben die Vereinigte Entwickler-Community daran arbeitet, diese äh zu beseitigen, ne? Ein ein lebhaftes Forschungsprojekt.
Na ja, beim BND äh schläft es irgendwann ein, so ein bisschen, weil die wie so oft ihren Laden äh umstrukturieren, dann übernimmt eine Person namens MS die Leitung des Projekts und beschwert sich
über knappere die knappe Ressource brillantes Personal und mangelndes Interesse innerhalb des BND Tor zu knacken.
Nachdem das damals einmal intern vorgestellt wurde, sei nichts mehr gekommen und,
dann wird aber die Weiterentwicklung auf den Bedarf des Partners ausgerichtet denn der NS die NSA,
hat etwas, was der BND gern hätte.
Und jetzt optimiert der BND quasi darauf, also der der BND sagt, eine nicht näher genannte Technologie aus dem Bereich der Kryptoanalyse, also Knacken von von Kryptographie. Ähm möchte.
Der BND gerne haben und weiß, dass die NSA die hat, aber ungern hergeben wird und dann denkt sich der BND, na dann gut, dann greifen wir jetzt halt Tor an und äh tauschen,
vielleicht mit der mit der NSA unseren Torangriff gegen deren Kryptoangriff.
Interessant ist, dass dann zweitausendzehn äh eine
Meldung an Regierungsbehörden rausgeht, der anonymisierungsdienst Tor wird weltweit neben der Verschleierung der Identität des Nutzers auch zur Umgehung von Zensurmaßnahmen verwendet. Allerdings werden die Daten ströten
Frömme nicht konsequent verschlüsselt, sodass sich für Nachrichtendienste und Strafverfolgungsbehörden Überwachungsansätze bieten. Darüber hinaus besteht die Möglichkeit selbst sogenannte
Exit-Knoten zur Überwachung einzurichten. Selbst sogenannte Exekutentsüberwachung einzurichten
Aus diesem Grund ist die Nutzung des Tornetzes zur Durchführung von Computernetzwerkoperationen für Nachrichtendienste ungeeignet. Ähm.
Das war das Beispiel, man macht einen Exit auf, das heißt, da kommt der Traffic raus und wenn die Tornutzer dann unverschüsselt darüber kommunizieren,
dann sie kannst du diese Inhalte natürlich einsehen und wenn sie unverschüsselt sind, kannst du sie auch manipulieren und es gibt immer wieder so äh Rog, Exit Notes, wo du quasi sagst, okay, du du injizierst,
etwas in den unverschlüsselten Traffic irgendwie so ein Exploid und versuchst damit Tornutzer anzugreifen, ne? Also äh es gibt einen Reichtum an.
Werkzeugen. Interessanter an dieser Veröffentlichung ist das ähm der BND.
Schon so lange an der Sache dranhängt. Diese Warnmail nun ja, also man muss jetzt echt nicht, also um zu sagen, es gibt Rock Exits Notes, musste man zweitausendzehn jetzt nicht besonders klug sein,
Aber dass die schon zweitausendzehn ihre Behörden davor warnen, das zu nutzen
macht auf jeden Fall hellhörig, ja? Weil wenn es äh bis wenn es da wirklich äh Angriffe gibt, die zweitausend zehn schon so realistisch waren, dass man andere davor warnen muss, das überhaupt zu benutzen. Dann besteht hier die Sorge, dass die etwas wissen,
was wir nicht wissen. Tja, schön.
Es gibt ein Statement äh von Julius Mitten zwei, der äh ist eine,
einen ein bekannteres Mitglied im Chaos Computerclub, der war auch im Bord von Thor ähm einige Zeit und ist auch heute noch im Torprojekt aktiv und er sagt sinngemäß, na ja,
Wenn man sich anschaut, wie viel Traffic so ein Torexit rauswirft, ja? Und wie's wie wenige.
Schriftstücke wir bekommen wegen illegaler Aktivitäten in diesem Tornetz. Dann ist es ganz offensichtlich, dass hier der größere Teil des Traffics,
nicht illegal ist und nicht für illegale Zwecke äh geführt wird. Es gibt ähm natürlich
Beschwerden über irgendwelche, ne? Leute nutzen das und schreiben dann irgendeinen Hasskommentar irgendwohin oder so. Und ich will das auch nicht ähm,
Kleinreden, das sind Arschgeigen, die hier eine notwendige Anonymisierungstechnologie in Verruf bringen.
Aber es ist, ist eben trotzdem eine große Minderheit,
der Nutzer dieses Netzwerkes und das wenn da von Seiten der Strafverfolger behauptet wird, die sind achtundneunzig Prozent illegaler Aktivität, ähm die haben da tatsächlich keine Zahlen für und gegen so eine äh,
So eine Rufschädigung eines Anonymisierungsnetzwerkes muss man sich dann schon auch wehren.
Was denkst du, ist jetzt so der aktuelle Stand beim BND? Ist das irgendwie erahnbar.
Leider nicht so wirklich, also von dem, was ich hier lese hm.
Ist halt auch alles schon ein bisschen her.
Ich mein wir haben der der aktuelle Stand der beste Indikator für den aktuellen Stand ist eigentlich, dass inzwischen das FBI regelmäßig so hin Services hoch nimmt, ne? Ähm,
Ich weiß grade gar nicht mehr genau, um welchen es sich da gehandelt hat, aber da hatten die Unterstützung. Wir haben das im Logbuch Netzpolitik behandelt. Äh da hatten die Unterstützung von der KNEG Mellenuniversität und da war nachher irgendwie so die Rede von, dass das, dass der Angriff.
Äh vielleicht eine knappe Million gekostet hätte insgesamt. Ähm.
Und das ist so für mich der beste Indikator, äh dass es eigentlich nicht besonders gut im Tor steht. Also ich würde mich da, ich werde da jetzt auch.
Vorsichtig.
Tatsache, dass es eine Million gekostet hat oder.
Relativ wenig, ne? Ähm wenn du sagst, äh also ich meine, wenn du wenn du einen Hinservice betreibst,
den betreibst du ja, weil du es unmöglich machen möchtest, diesen Server zu finden
Und dieser Server ist im Zweifelsfall auch an dich gebunden. Den hast du irgendwo bezahlt oder es gibt irgendwo im Rechenzentrum steht dran, wem der gehört. Also du du hast im Zweifelsfall nicht wirklich einen anonymen Server, ja?
Sobald jemand deine IP-Adresse hat, wenn du jetzt das deine Bedrohung ist, was weiß ich, China oder die NSA oder das FBI ähm dein Trad Modell May very. Ähm.
Und du gehst davon aus, dass dass die nur eine,
hoch sechsstellige bis siebenstellige Summe brauchen um dich um dich zu finden,
und dass das auch immer billiger werden wird, dann willst du eigentlich echt kein Onien-Service mever betreiben.
Ne, also zumindest nicht mit dem mit der Maßgabe, dass dass du dich dabei verstecken möchtest. Es gibt noch andere Gründe, die zu betreiben. Zum Beispiel, dass die eben, dass du deinen Nutzern bei der, bei der, bei der Anwendung deines Dienstes,
absolute Anonymität bietest und Gewissheit, dass du nicht weißt, wer sie sind,
dass du eine, dass du ordentliche, saubere Verschlüsselung hast und zwar mehrfach angebracht, ja? Es gibt nicht
Es gibt verschiedene Gründe, Onjendienste anzubieten, äh die darüber hinaus gehen, dass du nicht möchtest, wo der Server steht. Beispielsweise, wenn ich jetzt sage, okay, ich mache ein Logbuchnetzpolitik
äh Dot Onian, also Logbuch, XY hast du nicht gesehen, Ondien.
Und ermögliche Leuten dadurch äh Lokbuch Netzpolitik zu abonnieren und zu hören und zu besuchen,
dann äh hab muss ich mich ja nicht verstecken. Ich weiß, also jeder weiß ja, wo der Server steht und wie der aussieht und ähm trotzdem wäre es eine.
Wissen, wo dein Server steht.
Ähm äh trotzdem wäre es eine erhöhte Sicherheit und Anonymität bei der Nutzung für unsere Hörer. Und allein in sich schon die Arbeit wert, wenn ich sie dann irgendwann mal machen würde.
Scheiße jetzt, das wird muss ich jetzt echt mal machen, ne?
Kein Stress, aber noch genug andere Sachen zu tun.
Ja. Ja. Aber so, dass das Entdecken von von,
Das T-Maskieren von Tor Clients und Hidden Services wird langsam aber sicher,
offenbar billig genug, dass man es im Rahmen der regulären Strafverfolgung auch mal zur Anwendung bringen kann,
Und ähm jetzt mögen viele sagen eine Million Dollar, äh das ist ja wahnsinnige Summe. Nee, es ist leider nicht
Ne? Also äh wenn wir von technischer Sicherheit sprechen, dann müssen wir eher von, es muss mehr Dollar kosten, als es Atome im Universum gibt, reden, weil ähm sonst wird's halt einfach mit absehbarer Zeit
zu billig und ist dann eben einfach kaputt, ne? Also.
Gut, gibt's da noch was zu sagen?
Nö, eigentlich wollte ich da jetzt auch direkt anschließen. Heute ist ja die feierliche Eröffnung der der Zitis.
Genau, weil jetzt geht's weiter sozusagen. Jetzt.
Ja und ich habe immer noch nicht, ich muss jetzt nochmal kurz gucken, wofür City steht, das kriege ich in diesem Leben nicht mehr hin. Zentralstelle komm, hilf mir mal eben Tim.
Zentralstelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich. Citis.
Die wird am Donnerstag in München, also heute am vierzehnten September in München eröffnet und äh wie wir uns erinnern soll, dass quasi diese äh Dienstleistungsbehörde für die Sicherheitsbehörden werden, damit ähm,
Also der BRD oder das in LKA oder ein BKA dort quasi Sachen in Auftrag geben kann und die Zitis tritt als Dienstleister,
auf und sie bietet. Digitale Forensik. Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Brechen von Verschlüsselungen,
Technische Fragen der Spionageabwehr und die Auswertung von Big Data. Also zum Beispiel das Ausforschen von sozialen Netzwerken in Echtzeit an,
Schön, dass wir dafür jetzt eine eine unabhängige Börde haben, die das die dieses Wissen Geheimdiensten und Polizei gleichermaßen zur Verfügung stellen will
Und da fragt man sich natürlich
wo woher will man denn das Personal für so eine Behörde haben, ne? Also es soll ja irgendwie hundertzwanzig Leute da arbeiten. Ja ähm ganz einfach, man holt sich in ein Expendler,
Wilfried Karl ist der Chef dieser Zitis, äh der war fünfundzwanzig Jahre beim BND. Zuletzt kommissarischer Leiter der Abteilung,
Technische Aufklärung und wie sagte die Abteilung technische Aufklärung.
War ja äh einer der Hauptdarsteller im NSA und so auch Wilfried Karl, der war allein vier Mal dort äh und hat unter anderem so interessante Thesen vertreten, wie das Metadaten nicht personenbezogen seien.
Ja? Ähm, BND, technische Aufklärung unter anderem ähm dafür verantwortlich, dass äh auf deutschem Boden äh.
Internetdaten und Telefongespräche äh nicht nur abgefangen wurden, sondern auch an ausländische Dienste weitergegeben wurden.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, genau die richtige Abteilung, äh der man da jetzt irgendwie, die man jetzt mit dieser Aufgabe betrauen würde.
Und ich ein weiterer Schritt, ja diese diese Trennung von,
Polizei und Geheimdiensten aufzulösen, ne.
Die wir immer beklagen.
Die Compate. Wir beklagen nicht die Trennung, wir die Auflösung.
Nein, die Auflösung der Bitte der Trennung ja genau.
Interessant ist, hm was die,
Also was die machen werden, ist genau das, was wir die ganze Zeit kritisieren, nämlich Schwachstellen geheim halten. Der,
Die entscheidende Argumentation, die der Chaos-Computerclub weit seit sechsunddreißig Jahren äh und ich in weiß nicht drei Sachverständigengutachten mindestens an den,
Bundestag vorgebracht habe ist, wenn es Schwachstellen gibt.
Dann ist es immer besser, die zum Wohle aller zu schließen,
statt sie zum Unwohle aller geheim zu halten. Und was dabei rauskommt, wenn Behörden Schwachstellen geheim halten wollen, sehen wir eben bei so One Acrylgeschichten.
Wenn deren Wissen dann auf einmal in
andere Hände gelangt. Und da stellen sich dann diese Citisleute hin und sagen, ja, aber wer, nee, nee, wir machen, wir halten das ja geheim,
für den und wir machen das ja nur für den BND und für das BKA und für Robin Hood und für die heilige Jungfrau Maria, das hilft nicht
wenn diese Schwachstelle trotzdem auf unser aller äh Systeme schlummert und andere diese Schwachstellen auch ausnutzen können, ja? Und wenn ihr, ich meine, man, ich komme ja manchmal vor, als würde ich vor die Wand reden.
Ja. Du äh hier die gleichen Leute, die rumschreien und Panik machen, weil der Ivan irgendwas hackt, ja?
Die sitzen da und horten jetzt oh Days, ja? Das ist einfach sowas von absurd, ja? Und das sind übrigens auch die gleichen Leute, habe ich gestern noch in einem in einem Interview.
Festgestellt, die die sagen ja die die Anzahl der Angriffe aus Russland hat fürchterlich zugenommen,
Ähm oder die Angriffsaktivität hat zugenommen und es ist einfach so eine Stussaussage, ja? Weil wenn ich,
Meine Anstrengungen jemanden anzugreifen, erhöhe, ne? Dann mache ich nicht einfach mehr desgleichen, was sie schon abgewehrt haben, sondern ich mache weniger und besser,
ja? Also ein, also die reden den ganzen Tag nur Stuss und man fragt sich ernsthaft, ob die das glauben.
Was sie da reden oder äh oder ob sie das wieder wieder besseren Wissens machen. In beiden Fällen sind es auf jeden Fall nicht die richtigen Leute.
Ja, verkauft man sowas ja auch politisch, ne?
Aber dann sagen sie ähm dann sagen sie ähm es wird keinen Ankauf von Zero Days auf grau und Schwarzmärkten geben. Es gibt keine Zusammenarbeit mit unseriösen Firmen.
Und wir schaffen keine Sicherheitslücken, diese existieren bereits und sind seit Jahren bekannt. Na toll, du,
dann fix sie doch bitte in, dann denk doch bitte an das Risiko an äh und indem wir alle ausgesetzt sind, ne? Also die Leute, die jetzt für unsere Sicherheit sorgen wollen
nutzen behaupten, sie wüssten von Sicherheitsmitteln, die seit Jahren bekannt sind, die sie nun ausnutzen werden, statt die endlich mal zu beheben.
Ne. Ähm der einzige Satz, der vielleicht echt stimmt, ist IT-Sicherheit ist ein Managementproblem, da würde ich vielleicht noch zustimmen.
Aber genau deshalb sollte man diese Leute auch nicht mit dem Management betrauen. Ähm.
Wir sollten aber diese Zitate auf jeden Fall äh rot markieren und äh uns anstreichen, weil ich könnte mir sehr, sehr gut vorstellen, dass die früher oder später da ähm.
Niemand hat die Absicht als Siroder.
Sievert hat die Absicht eines Simodellen zu kaufen.
So, ich musste mal eben Fenster zumachen. Also herzlich willkommen in der Zitis ähm und ich kann nur sagen,
vielleicht haben wir ja den ein oder anderen Zuhörer ähm,
der mit dem Gedanken spielt sich da zu bewerben, kann da nur sagen ähm.
Überlegt euch doch einfach auf welcher Seite äh ihr eure
euer Wissen über IT-Security anbringen möchtet, ja? Wollt ihr die Gesellschaft voranbringen oder wollt ihr hier mit irgendwelchen Leuten
agieren, die
sich damit brüsten die Gesellschaft auf dem Niveau von vor vielen Jahren zurückzuhalten. Und ich bin eigentlich ganz froh, dass wir da gerade als Chaos-Computerclub wieder auch eine
positives Beispiel für IT-Sicherheitsforschung liefern konnten ähm,
wo also na ja, auch wenn es halt Schrott ist, den niemand benutzen sollte
immerhin das Wissen in die Welt gesetzt wird und der Druck erhöht wird, äh, diese Schwachstellen zu beseitigen.
So, wir haben's ja schon äh erwähnt und es kommt wieder sehr überraschend, aber es ist Wahlkampf. Und es ist ja auch Bundestagswahl demnächst. Ähm.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt selber gerade so ein bisschen überrascht, als ich aufs Datum geguckt habe, dass das ja quasi jetzt bald ist.
Also jetzt ist noch zehn Tage. Und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, es ist noch gar nichts äh passiert,
Ist vielleicht auch ganz gut so, muss sagen, also man kann sich jetzt lange natürlich über die Langweiligkeit und die,
ja mangelnder Aufregung, ich weiß nicht, ob es mangelnder äh wahrscheinlich konsumiere ich einfach die falschen Medien, das kann natürlich auch sein. Aber bei mir geht's irgendwie so ein bisschen dran vorbei. Aber ich bin ja auch nicht wahlberechtigt, von daher.
Da ein bisschen raus. Ähm tja ist irgendwas passiert.
Also was mich was mich ärgert an diesem an dieser Wahlsituation.
Ist das gefühlte fünfundneunzig Prozent der Berichterstattung, die Strategien behandelt, die die Parteien anwenden, um den Wahlkampf zu gewinnen,
Aber kaum über die Bedeutung der Inhalte gesprochen wird.
Ja.
Und ich habe erst gedacht, dafür mache ich mal die Medien verantwortlich, dass die so ein
Weißt du so und Lindner versucht es über rechts außen, doch da steht schon Alice Wedel mit ihrer syrischen, schwarzbeschäftigten Putzfrau und auch der Ball ist im Aus, wird Martin Schulz ihn nochmal einwerfen können. Nein, er fordert ein erneutes TV.
Halbzeit.
Und Angela Merkel souverän hier auf der Gamescom keine Patzer äh toll und.
3D Brille sitzt.
Und die drei Youtuber äh sind aufgeregt. Na, wie freust du dich, dass du die Kanzlerin drehst? Na, ich freue mich, dass ich jetzt endlich mal wahrgenommen werde.
Mein erstes Interview.
Du denkst dir irgendwie so äh so ist irgendwie jetzt auf dem Niveau von Bauer sucht, Frau.
Und ähm dann habe ich aber.
Bauern.
Weiß ich nicht. Gucke ich nämlich auch.
Was? So, wir sind raus aus dem Medienzirkus.
Und dann und dann auch also auch irgendwie äh selbst dieser also ich finde das sogar interessant, ja? Also wenn du dann so ein äh Podcast hörst wie Stimmenfang von Spiegel Online, wo dann mal so die Strategien der
Parteien sitziert werden oder so, ne? Oder die inneren, die Interior Workings äh die.
Interessant ist es nämlich nur in Podcast.
Okay, also da ich höre mir das an. Ähm aber ich würde ja,
ähm doch ganz gerne mal allen Beteiligten in Erinnerung rufen, dass wir da eine Entscheidung über die nächsten vier oder fünf Jahre unseres Landes machen, weil ja jetzt gerade diskutiert wird, sogar die Legislaturperioden um fünf Jahre auf fünf Jahre zu erweitern oder sowas, ne. Ähm,
Also wir machen eine Entscheidung für die nächsten vier Jahre und die sollte doch bitte inhaltlich sein und ähm es was mir zum Beispiel fehlt ist, wenn da einer sagt, hier äh wir,
schütten, Steuergelder aus und machen euch alle reich, dass dann irgendwo mal Stratege kommt und sagt, ja geht oder geht nicht,
Aber so 'ne inhaltliche Bewertung,
findet in meiner Wahrnehmung kaum statt. Und das finde ich ähm.
Das finde ich ärgerlich und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das scheinen die Parteien auch selber zu betreiben, ja? Ähm und das scheinen nicht nur die Medien schuld zu sein. Kleiner Beispielfall, wo ich wirklich ähm,
wo ich wirklich Kopfschmerzen bekommen habe in in Berlin-Friedrichshain, wo ich ja wohne, tapeziert die.
Tapezierten die lokalen Grünen ein Plakat mit der Aufschrift die Häuser dehnen, die drin wohnen. Ja? So.
Jetzt frage ich mich, wenn ich jetzt die Grünen wähle, ne? Heißt das, ich kriege meine Wohnung,
Heißt das, dass Haus gehört mir bald? Soll ich das jetzt als ein Wahlversprechen auffassen? Ähm oder kann ich das ehrlich gesagt einfach mal auffassen als eine blöde Anwiederung,
an in einem in einem Ort, der gerade unter einer massiven Gentrifizierung leidet und wo Leute halt einfach unter massiven
Mieterhöhung leiden, ja? Wo so ein Spruch einfach gut klingt. Aber kann ich den, kann ich den, den kann ich doch nicht ernsthaft als Partei vertreten. Und dann,
passiert auch noch das Folgende, die Bundesgrünen müssen sich dann auch noch davon distanzieren.
Äh weil sie natürlich WLAN nicht nur in Berlin Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg suchen, sondern irgendwie äh deutschlandweit und wenn äh die Münchner denen die Häuser gehören in Berlin dieses Plakat sehen von den Grünen, dann kriegen nämlich schlechte Laune. So.
Und und wenn also ich meine dann denkst du doch wirklich, habt ihr eigentlich alle irgendwie Klebstoff geschnüffelt? Das ist doch wirklich also ich meine, das ist doch einfach Scheiße.
Und das, das ist nämlich kein inhaltlicher Wahlkampf. Das ist ein ein irgendwie ein emotions Wahlkampf. Aber da da wird nicht ernsthaft mal über ein Problem gesprochen. Die Lösung.
Wenn sie dir wahrscheinlich äh beantworten, wenn du sie fragst so, na ja, ist mit Inhalt, das haben wir schon mal probiert, aber äh das will ja auch keiner ran.
Rüberbringen und will jetzt auch noch nicht mal sagen, dass das niemandem gelingt,
Emotion, die dann letzten Endes auch ausschlaggebend ist. Denn am Ende war es ja eh nicht, in welcher Koalition oder Opposition du landest. Also manche wissen das vielleicht schon, aber äh manche wissen's halt auch nicht.
Ich denke es ist auch ganz unzweifelhaft, dass politische Realität einfach was mit Kompromissen zu tun hat und dass man eigentlich nicht sehr viel mehr machen kann als zu sagen so. Also in einer idealen Welt
Ja, würden wir gerne, dass es in die Richtung geht und dafür stehen wir. So.
Was würden wir denn, als würden wir denn äh auf Plakate schreiben als Lobbuchnetzpolitik.
Würden doch auch an appellieren doch hier auch meine die Emo.
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall eine Reihe an äh konkreten inhaltlichen äh Forderungen, würde ich sagen. Und die könnten die würde man im Zweifelsfall auch auf ein.
Zero D-Kauf abschaffen.
Ja
Passt gerade noch aufs Plakat.
Wir sind jetzt glaube ich gerade an dem Punkt, äh dass wir.
Äh dass wir wählen sie LNP.
Ich beschwere mich gerade über über die,
über die über diese Strategie Besprechung im Wahlkampf und äh wir machen es jetzt auch, ne? Aber sagen wir mal so, also wir haben ein bisschen Probleme im im Bereich der,
der Produktmängel, ja, IT-Security-Mängel in Produkten, diese ganzen verrotzten Android-Telefone, die irgendwie bei bei Aldi im Regal lagen und ihr Lebtag kein kein Softwareupdate mehr gesehen haben. Da könnte man so mal als im Rahmen des Verbraucherschutzes äh drangehen,
Selbstverständlich, was du gerade sagst äh Zero Day, Kauf abschaffen, also,
staatliches Geld soll nicht in Unsicherheit, sondern in Sicherheit gehen,
Ähm sowieso Lücken dich geheim halten, ne. Ähm.
Natürlich Netzneutralität und Netzausbau. Das ist übrigens tatsächlich etwas, was äh was sich auch in den Wahlprogrammen findet, ja? Also äh Netzausbau. Das wären so Sachen, da könnte man eigentlich mal eine Partei vergründen.
Die LMP. Die Linus Neumann Partei, ja.
Die Lokbuch-Gesetzpolitik Partei.
Linus Neumann stürmt dann über links überrennt die Grünen Verteidiger.
Schauen wir uns da mal schauen wir uns mal die die Situation an. Wir haben jetzt vier Jahre große Koalition gehabt. Wir haben dieses dieses lächerliche IT-Sicherheitsgesetz. Äh wir haben entweder kamen sie noch, als sie gesehen haben, das ist irgendwie Murks. Kamen sie mit der Cyber-Wehr,
dann kam irgendwie letztens ja ähm der Demazier nochmal mit einer Cyberfeuerwehr. Haben wir ja dann auch gemacht,
dicken Feuerwehrschlauch auf die Wahl gehalten. Jetzt ist er auch am Quengel, ja? Ähm dann.
Dann kommt ein Anti, wie sie irgendwie Antiterror-Paket, BND gesetzt, der NS Auer, wo jetzt gerade, äh, wo man Anne Roth jetzt gerade auf Twitter zusehen kann, wie sie die Akten alle in den, in die großen Schredderkartons packt.
Also nicht eine Rutsch tut es, sondern sie berichtet darüber, dass es getan, al.
Muss das tun, sie muss das tun.
Sie muss es jetzt schreddern, ja, verstehe, also er siehst ja äh.
Sie war ja äh sie war da ja ähm ähm nicht Assistentin, wie, wie, wie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die.
Wie nennt man, wie weit ihr nicht offiziell sie war, äh wie nennt man das Sachbearbeiter? Sie hat die Arbeit gemacht.
Ja. Stimmt. Assistentin ist eigentlich. Na ja.
Stimmt auch Assistentin ist eigentlich der Begriff für jemanden, der die, der die eigentliche Arbeit macht, ist dann immer äh Assistent oder Assistentin, ja. Äh Referentin oder so ist, glaube ich, der offiziell.
Ja ich.
Oh man. Die hört uns, die wird jetzt richtig.
Oh Gott, Sorry, wir schauen. Mitleid. Mit dem. Absolut.
Sorry Anne, wir haben wir haben Mitleid, mit mit dem, dass man also sie sagt ja auch so, die Iro,
hat diese ganzen, sie hat diese ganzen Akten ja nur auf Papier bekommen, ne, um das Lieken zu verhindern und und jetzt müssen sie das alles wieder verschrotten.
Nur für den Dienstgebrauch.
So, dann haben wir hier irgendwie Videoüberwachung, äh dann haben wir den den äh standardmäßig wird den äh wird ähm
Personen hier, die ähm die Asyl beantragen, das Handy ausgelesen. Ja, war ein Staatstrojaner haben wir bekommen. Dann haben wir eine Citis bekommen. Ich meine, Freunde, ganz ehrlich, es gab kein
keine vier Jahre, die bescheidener waren als die.
Es ist wirklich ähm ziemlich übel, was uns hier in den letzten Jahren um die Ohren geflogen ist. Und ähm.
Man kann sich eben überlegen, ob man in dieser Richtung weitermachen möchte oder nicht und es gibt natürlich Parteien, die in den letzten vier Jahren wenigstens mal gezeigt haben, dass sie dagegen kämpfen.
Zumindest so lange sie nicht in der Region sind.
Zumindest solange sie nicht an der Regierung sind, ja. Insofern,
könnte man ja sich, könnte man daraus ja auch eine eine Wahlentscheidung ableiten, die nicht darauf basiert ist, was auf irgendein Plakat steht,
sondern die darauf basiert ist, wie sich Personen in
In vergangenen Jahren verhalten haben und Parteien, das ist immer noch übrigens auch in der Psychologie einer der besten Predigtoren zukünftigen Verhaltens ist, wann hat die Person beim letzten Mal gemacht, als sie in der Situation war, ne.
Ähm insofern könnte man sich da beschäftigen, dann gibt es natürlich den Wahlomat, ja, der ist jetzt wieder da, da kann man irgendwie kann man dann sagen, was man richtig und was man falsch findet.
Ja, wobei das ist ja sozusagen auch immer nur die Aufzählung der Versprechen. Äh es gibt auch noch ist, wie heißt denn dieser andere äh.
Ist nämlich der andere Digitalomat.
Nee, es gibt noch einen, der sich nämlich nicht daran orientiert, was jetzt in den in den Programmen steht, sondern sich daran orientiert, was äh in den letzten Jahren auch tatsächlich getan wurde.
Den kenne ich nicht, den will ich haben.
Ja den will ich auch haben und jetzt fällt mir ums Verrecken gerade der Name nicht ein verdammt,
dein, dein Wahl heißt das Ding, genau und das ist sozusagen das.
Geiler Wahl.
Gleiche für sich eigentlich immer einen guten Ansatz, ne? Weil da werden halt nicht nur die Versprechen analysiert, sondern dieses Jahr, was habt ihr denn konkret getan? Ähm ja.
Genau, ähm hier sagen die Parteien nicht, wie sie zu einem Thema abstimmen würden, hier zählt, wie sie zu einem Thema abgestimmt haben. Das unterscheidet deinen Wahl. Übrigens auch von den typischen Wahlprogrammen. Sehr schön. Ähm.
Dein Wahl mit VAL und nicht Wahl, ne? Das ist deiner Wahl.
Der ist süß.
Kleine Wahl.
Und dann gibt's noch irgendwie wen äh minus Wählen DE, wo auch irgendwie relativ viel Informationen so sind. Hm.
Tja. Geben wir eine Wahlempfehlung ab.
Ich würd 'ne Wahlempfehlung abgeben. Hingehen, auf jeden Fall mitmachen.
Ja, irgendwas wählen, was äh nicht klar äh,
Nationalistische und äh rassistische und ähnliche achtenswürdige Grundeinstellungen Zuschauer trägt. Und ansonsten.
Wüsste ich auch ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal so ganz genau,
ob überhaupt gerade eine Konstellation gibt, die einerseits äh realistisch über Lebens äh fähig ist und äh andererseits auch äh ausreichend wünschenswert. Am Ende muss ja der Druck.
Gesamte Parlament gemacht werden. Ja, äh gerade weil Parteien wenn sie,
quasi ins Regierungslager äh wechseln, auch nachvollziehbarerweise,
Anderen Zwängen ausgesetzt sind, ne? Wir werden das jetzt vielleicht sehen, wenn die SPD dann doch vielleicht nicht mehr in der Regierung ist, das ist ja durchaus eine Möglichkeit
wir diese GroKo zumindest loswerden, ob's dann irgendwie besser wird, sagen wir mal dahin gestellt
aber ist zumindest denkbar, natürlich werden wir dann der SPD dabei zusehen, wie sie da dann auf einmal wieder linkere Positionen zelebrieren wird und irgendwie gegen Dinge protestiert, wo man sich dann fragt, so sag mal, äh ist das nicht das, was ihr gerade in den letzten vier Jahren irgendwie beschlossen äh habt so, ja?
Weil's dann eben nicht so wichtig ist, da kann man dann einfach mal fordern
am Ende zählt halt die Resilienz innerhalb einer Regierungskoalition und hier hängt dann auch immer von dem Personal ab, was gerade wirkt.
Ja, du musst wissen, dass das Wahlprogramm der SPD ist all das, was die SPD gemacht hätte, wenn sie in den letzten vier Jahren in der Regierung gewesen wäre.
Quasi. Quasi. Ja.
Quasi. Und das Gegenteil.
Ja, weil ich denke, da sind auch die anderen nicht äh befreit von, ja. Also ich meine, auch äh auch so eine äh,
da sind auch irgendwie alle gespalten, ja, zumal ja auch jede Partei,
Mindestens immer zwei Flügel, wenn nicht sogar noch sehr viel mehr Flügel hat. Diese in irgendeiner Form unter einen Hut bekommen muss.
Das ist ja auch der demokratische Prozess und ich habe ja auch schon öfter mal gesagt, dass wir das völlig egal ist, wer das Richtige macht. Hauptsache, dass es getan wird, ja. Ähm insofern äh hilft hier auch,
muss hier einfach
positive, vernünftige Utopie für die Gesellschaft wieder her. Das löst du jetzt nicht mit äh wir wählen alle diese oder jene Partei, sondern es muss einfach die gesamte Gesellschaft an einem Punkt wieder kommen, wo wir
Mut zu einem besseren Morgen entwickeln statt die ganze Zeit nur aus Angst vor einem schlechteren heute,
irgendwie voranzumarschieren. Und irgendwie,
Davon ist ja diese diese Politik ist mehr denn je von irgendwie Angst und Vermeidung und Verhinderung und an altem Festhalten geprägt, ja? Ähm.
Und wir es ist klappt,
Die kriegen also die kommen damit durch. Also ein bestes Beispiel ist, ich meine, da da das war ja wirklich auch es gibt so Momente, wo man merkt, okay, fuck so, wir ähm,
Die die sind gerade echt auf dem Vormarsch und das war zum Beispiel hier so diese Welt am Sonntag vom siebenundzwanzigsten August zweitausendsiebzehn die hier groß ähm,
Über das Buch Ninety AT vorschreibt. Ninety Nighty for ähm.
Ein äh Roman von George Orwell sollte, also eines der Bücher, die man einfach gelesen haben muss,
So würde ich sagen, es gibt keine gibt's jetzt nicht irgendwie sowas wie man kann mitdiskutieren und hat Nighting vor nicht gelesen.
Zumindest mal den Film angeschaut haben.
Oder zumindest den Film angeschaut oder von mir aus auch nur den Apple Werbespot.
Äh also ein Buch über eine eine Überwachungsdystopie.
Wir bieten hier wirklich einen einfachen Zugang zu Politik und Gesellschaft, ne? Ja, ja, ja.
Ist für jeden was dabei, ne? Muss die Leute da abholen, wo sie stehen.
Der winkt mir auch links auf alle drei äh Quellen.
So, also ein Buch über einen totalitären Staat, in dem Überwachung eine Rolle spielen, in dem Geschichtsrevisionismus eine Rolle spielen.
In dem auch das Gefüge,
zwischen den Staaten und auch das Gefüge zwischen gesellschaftlichen Schichten eine Rolle spielen, ähm großartiges Buch, ähm über das man sich echt lange Gedanken machen kann.
Und über dieses Buch steht hier riesengroß äh auf dieser Welt und ich glaube, es ist aber auf der
Seite, ne? Das ist, steht auf jeden Fall der Preis drauf. Das Lieblingsbuch aller U-Bahn-Schubser, Vergewaltiger, Heroindealer, Terrorplaner, Grapscher, Taschendiebe,
Münzenräuber, Schläger und Hooligans. Über den Ursprung der absurden deutschen Angst vor der Kameraüberwachung.
Das Ganze natürlich in dem Kontext dieser äh Südkreuzgeschichte, ne?
Was habt ihr euch denn so? Das tut do.
Wenn die schon so trommeln, ja? Und das sind, das sind und am Ende, also ich habe den Artikel auch gelesen, der Autor ähm versucht dann hier irgendwie
zu sagen, wir hätten alle Ninetin ATV nicht richtig verstanden, in Wirklichkeit würde das von was ganz anderem handeln, also wirklich katastrophaler, katastrophaler Stuss, ja. Und man fragt sich auch ernsthaft, ob dieser Mensch.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, bei, dass bei der Welt am Sonntag jemand so Dummes schreibt. Und das ist immer, also ne, man soll ja immer,
nicht mit,
Bösartigkeit erklären, was man auch mit Dummheit erklären kann. Aber wenn sowas in der Welt am Sonntag gedruckt wird, dann sind da halt mehrere äh dran beteiligt gewesen, dass sowas nicht nur gedruckt, sondern offenbar anscheinend hier auch auf die Titelseite gedruckt wurde
Und dann kann, dann bleibt der,
der dann bleibt die die Ausrede, Dummheit wird halt irgendwie immer schmaler, ne? Und das ist hier eine eine aktive wirklich ekelige,
Hetze und das ist genau der Geschichtsrevisionismus der in Ninety Natifour so ausführlich behandelt wird. Also es gibt immer mal wieder so Dinge da der Gefritz einem in den Adern,
und man merkt wie wie hier vorgegangen wird und wie hier Menschen ja äh regelrecht gehetzt werden,
aufgehetzt werden in diesen Überwachungsstaat,
Und das ist echt ähm beängstigend. Und das einzige, was ich glaube, was ich, was einfach.
Was ich mir noch vorstellen kann, ist dem tatsächlich einfach trotz alledem,
positiven Utopie gegenüber zu treten. Und ich sehe, dass es schwer fällt,
ich beobachte das bei der, bei der Datenschutzbewegung, dass es die, dass es dir wirklich schwer fällt, ähm, in heutigen Zeiten, wo es eigentlich mehr denn je,
Grund für Datenschutz gibt, ähm mit einem Konzept in die Öffentlichkeit zu treten.
Ähm das mehr ist als nur äh eine Abwehr, die das dem Gegner sehr leicht macht. Äh das als ein paar Verbliebene Aluhut-Aktivisten,
abzutun und das ist ja auch genau das, was seit was ich seit einem Jahr beobachte, was Strategie von Seiten des Innenministeriums ist von Seiten des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz, spricht dann immer von den,
Von diesen ewig gestrigen, die in den achtziger Jahren beim Volkszählungsurteil irgendwie hängengeblieben sind und nicht mitbekommen haben, dass wir jetzt in der Zukunft leben,
Und ähm solange man diese Angriffsfläche bietet, äh werden wir auch weiter solche.
Solche Veröffentlichungen sehen,
und müssen dann uns tatsächlich auch anschauen wie ein größerer Teil der Öffentlichkeit sowas sieht und sagt ja das mit den neunzehn vierundachtzig dass er raus ja und drehen dann irgendwie durch, ja? Und das ist wirklich bedauerlich.
Stellen wir gerade so ein Plakat vor mit das die Lieblingszeitung von Steuer hinterziehen, freier Freiheitsunterdrückern und Feindbildern.
Ja, sch.
Welt am Sonntag.
Ja, Tim. Ab ans Photoshop.
Gestern den Gregor hier gehabt, der mach.
Vielleicht finden mögen ja unsere äh Hörer da kreativ werden. Ich bin gerade sehr mit Podcastproduktion eingespannt.
Stimmt. Ich bin mal gespannt, bist du deine Stimme wieder kaputt hast, wenn du so weiter.
Ja, ja. Ja, die letzten vierundzwanzig Stunden haben da nicht geholfen, aber es geht noch.
Gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch Leute, die hier einfach mal lobend erwähnt werden müssen, weil die sich ernsthaft,
Durch diese Wahlprogramme gekämpft haben, ja? Also wir haben die Webseiten, die daraus resultieren äh schon erwähnt, Anabiselli
und ich glaube es machen unterschiedliche Autoren bei Netzkritik Oc. Ich habe glaube ich auch was von Thomas Rudel dazu gelesen. Ähm,
die setzen sich setzt sich mit dem digitalen Wahlprogramm auseinander. Sascha Lobo hat das auch bei Spiegel Online mal gemacht. Ja, aber man merkt auch, der hat ne, ist im Prinzip so, ich habe mir das angetan, ich hab's gelesen, damit ihr es nicht tun müsst.
Ne und dann steht da auch so. So so,
Die Breitbandstrategie der Bundesregierung Angela Merkel verkündet zweitausendacht zweitausendneun, zweitausendzehn, zweitausendelf, zweitausendzwölf, zweitausenddreizehn, zweitausendvierzehn, sowie zweitausendfünfzehn große Anstrengungen für schnelleres Internet,
Heute liegt Deutschland bei der Glasfaservernetzung, fallen für Home auf dem vorletzten Platz in Europa mit einer Durchdringungsrate von eins Komma sechs Prozent der EU-Durchschnitt ist
neun Komma vier Prozent. Russland nicht unbedingt ein Stadtstaat liegt bei vierunddreißig Prozent, ja? Also.
Ich sage es immer wieder,
das, da werden irgendwann die die Geschichtsbücher schreiben in diesen, in dieser spätrömischen Dekadenz Deutschlands sind die alle noch mit ihren Diesel ähm
mit ihren Dieselautos durch die Gegend gefahren und haben über die Elektroautos gelacht und meinten, sie bräuchten kein Internet,
und dass der Höhepunkt der Digitalisierung in Deutschland war die Manipulation der Dieselsteuergeräte.
Das fand ich übrigens gerade einen witzigen Spruch. Keine Ahnung, ich mag direkt mal twittern.
Würde. Keine Ahnung. Die Geheimdienste CDU CSU im Jahr, wo dies wurde da irgendwie, weißt du, wo es ein NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss gab, der zu,
zahlreichen Verstößen des BND gekommen ist, äh die der die CD CDU CSU und SPD in gleichen Schritten noch legalisiert haben, steht denn da,
Wir bekennen uns klar zum Bundesnachrichtendienst. Die Zusammenarbeit des BND mit anderen Diensten weltweit ist unerlässlich. Wahlkampfprogramm oder ja Wahlkampfprogramm kann man eigentlich sagen, CDU, CSU.
Und die SPD einfache und sichere Lösungen für die elektronische Identifizierung und Verschlüsselung wollen wir für jedermann verfügbar machen. Alter, die machen wir seit zwanzig Jahren verfügbar und nicht über die SPD.
Weißt du, haben die jetzt auf einmal Krypto äh Spezialisten an Bord? Was ist das denn schon wieder.
Ich man kann sich nur aufregen.
Traurig ist das. Es ist wirklich traurig und na ja, ich glaube halt, dass äh das Land geht vor die Hunde.
Die Ente ist nei.
Und dann müssen wir uns noch irgendwas einfallen lassen, was wir mit diesen Verrückten machen, ne,
Wo war das? Finsterwalde oder Fortfoto? Der hieß auch noch so geil dieses Dorf. Wurde mal so ARD Panorama hingegangen ist als Angela Merkel da war und das die war da.
Schreihälse oder was.
Schreiherz ist gut, ey. Die waren drauf. Die haben irgendwas genommen.
Was diese AfD-Trollstadt, die da irgendwie die.
Die hat ja im Sprit gesorfen.
Ne, die werden ja auch von der AfD mittlerweile schon in Bussen dahin gekarrt, also das ist ja sozusagen voll organisiert der ganze Kram.
Dass wir dem in den Bus dahin gekarrt. Na ja, ich meine, wir kriegen ja auch alle unser Demo Geld von der Antifahne.
Stimmt, ist über Überweisung eigentlich schon durch irgendwie diesen Monat.
Wie kann der Neumann sich das eigentlich leisten alles.
Der ist doch bezahlt.
Also das ist ja tatsächlich eine ähm eine von Lutz Bach, wo man in die Welt getragene Verschwörungstheorie, ne? Das Ausreden ist der Chaos-Computerclub.
Hast du doch schon gesehen, das ist schon irgendwie.
Alle halt irgendwie, ne?
Die Links-Grünen versifften sowieso und klar und hier der Neumann.
Das Outlingsgrün versiff.
Ja, der hat einen schwarz-roten großen Koalitionsdicker auf seinem Lap.
Das sind die schlimmst.
Die machen gemeinsame Sache.
Zum Heulen.
Alter. Ja, aber gegen irgendwas müssen wir, also wenn wenn jemand eine Lösung hat für die Verrückten da unten,
müssen wir uns auch echt was überlegen. Also macht mir auch Sorge. Das sind übrigens die Früchte der Bildungspolitik und der der jemand twitterte letztens irgendwie,
die Rendite der der überstürzten Wiedervereinigung kommt langsam aber sie kommt,
Ziemlich übel finde, aber natürlich klar, das sind Menschen ähm,
Ich jetzt hier leichtfertig als verrückte äh bezeichne die ähm seit äh zwanzig Jahren perspektivlos irgendwo im Wald sitzen,
und ähm die natürlich Existenzängste haben. Und die inzwischen so lange ignoriert wurden.
Und solange verarscht wurden, dass sie inzwischen lieber glauben, dass die äh Regierung, ne, irgendwie LSD ins Trinkwasser oder in Flugzeuge macht.
Chemtrails.
Als dass sie irgendwas glauben, was ihnen so ein Politiker noch sagt, ne? Und da, das ist das, was habe ich ja auch glaube ich schon mal in der Sendung hier erzählt. Das ist das, was ich glaube, woran wir eigentlich leiden. Das ist das, das zugrunde liegende Problem, dass dieser komplette,
politische Betrieb jedwede Glaubwürdigkeit verzockt hat und alles was die sagen, niemand mehr ernst nimmt.
Und zwar unabhängig davon, welche Partei das ist. Und deswegen hast du jetzt einen wachsenden Teil Leute, die sagen.
Mal wieder einer her, der einfache Sätze sagt und durchzieht. So und äh.
Alle rausschmeißt und dann es wird alles gut. Wird natürlich nicht alles gut, aber das ist äh die Botschaft kommt irgendwie nicht so richtig an.
Okay, anderes Thema.
Ja, Depper, Schlepper, Bauanfänger, also ich würde auch sagen, nehmt einfach teil an dieser äh Wahl, so sehe ihr äh könnt, vielleicht auch dadurch, dass ihr einfach mal eure Freunde mal fragt. Ich glaube, das ist äh auch ganz interessant, ob die denn wählen gehen
Und wenn die dann sagen, nie nicht denken, ihr macht das dann auch nicht, sondern vielleicht einfach mal so kurz äh die Zeit investieren und sagen so, hier, nee, mach mal.
Oder eben Briefwahl beantragen für die Stimmzettel, für die ausfüll.
Glaube ich für Briefwahl beantragen. Jetzt kannst du keine Briefwahl mehr beantragen. Also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass bestimmt drei Wochen vorher oder sowas.
Kann ja, kann man irgendwie.
Hingehen, Kreuz machen
ist auch mal ganz lustig, äh sich den Betrieb mal von der Nähe anzuschauen. Ich spreche jetzt hier vor allem mal so die ganz äh jungen Hörer an, die gegebenenfalls hier überhaupt das erste Mal zu einer Wahl aufgerufen sind, zumindest von der ersten Bundestagswahl,
soll's ja auch geben. Und ihr seid nämlich meistens diejenigen, die,
bisschen da denken oder zu früh da schon von diesem Virus angestachelt werden, sodass man sicher noch gar kein Bild gemacht hätte oder dass man ja da nichts beeinflussen kann oder so
Das Problem des mangelnden Fortschritts ist vor allem auch ein Altersproblem. Die Rentner.
Die haben das, die haben schon die komplette Tour inklusive Kuchen und Kaffee danach äh an diesem Sonntag eingeplant, ja
sitze aber noch ein Stückchen im Park und so und dann gehen sie da mit ihrer Rummigruppe da irgendwie hin und dann wird halt einfach abgestimmt, was schon immer abgestimmt wird und welches Plakat irgendwie am schönsten war
So und und das sind Leute, für die gibt's irgendwie im Wesentlichen zwei äh Themen, nämlich äh
Hauptsache äh ich kann hier noch weiterhin ruhig auf meiner Parkbank sitzen, aber die einfach so mit den ganzen modernen,
in Podcast und natürlich und die einfach so mit den modernen Entwicklungen nichts zu tun haben. Ich werfe denen das noch nicht mal vor. Ja, ich sage jetzt nicht, ihr Alten, ihr seid ja alle doof, aber ist einfach
Zwangsläufig so, dass die quasi eine ganz andere Motivation haben, politische Entscheidungen zu beeinflussen oder nicht zu beeinflussen
weil sie die nicht sehen, weil sie die auch nicht mehr spüren werden und weil vielleicht nicht jeder, der jetzt irgendwie über sechzig oder siebzig ist
davon beseelt ist, dass die Zukunft dann derjenigen, die jetzt noch äh fünfzehn, sechzehn äh achtzehn, zwanzig sind,
irgendwie toll ist oder es überhaupt auch gar nicht so sehen, dass dass mittlerweile eine ganz andere Zukunft ansteht
die Implikation von Klimawandel und die Implikation von äh Cyber.
Selbstverständlich einfach überhaupt nicht so richtig eingepreist bekommen und umso wichtiger ist es in dieser jungen Generation dann auch einfach einen äh entsprechendes Bild zu bekommen. Das ist eure Zukunft,
euer euer Ding, euer Planet, der gerade äh Hops genommen wird, euer Freiheit, die einfach nachhaltig,
gefährdet ist. Wir haben's ganz gut gehabt, was so die Freiheit betrifft.
Oder? Ich meine ich habe mir so in meinem Leben einfach über so dermaßen viele Dinge überhaupt gar kein Kopf machen müssen, weil so
dermaßen selbstverständlich war, was ich was ich alles tun und lassen konnte und welchen Freiheitsgrad ich genossen habe. Aber das ist halt einfach auch nicht garantiert,
Das kann einfach auch mal ganz schnell wieder weg sein. Gibt hier keine Garantie auf Reiz. Schon gar nicht in Deutschland. Die Nummer haben wir schon mal komplett
äh durchgespielt und haben gesehen, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Und das mag wahrscheinlich auch einer der Gründe sein, warum wir da jetzt so ein bisschen Late to the Game sind. Ja und die anderen halt in Polen, in Ungarn und so weiter, bereits dabei sind, ihre Freiheit einfach mal äh selber in den Mülleimer reinzustecken,
So, aber das ist hier alles noch verhinderbar. Das ist hier alles noch
durchaus rückdrehbar. Da ist überhaupt der der Drops ist nicht gelutscht. Und na klar waren die letzten vier Jahre irgendwie Scheiße und dieses und jenes und so. Aber Dinge kann man auch wieder zurückdrehen, Dinge kann man auch wieder eindämmen. Man kann da auch Widerstand zeigen und wenn dieser Widerstand gezeigt wird, dann dann tut sich da halt auch was. Und wenn's erstmal nur ein Wahlzettel ist.
Ich finde es sehr schön, dass du das äh das Revolution häufig dadurch äh passieren, dass die Alten aussterben, ne? Ist tatsächlich so, also ist auch in anderen Bereichen so.
Ja, aber mit unserer Wachstumspyramide gerade ähm stirbt da gerade wenig aus.
Deutschland muss sterben.
Soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen. Nee. Oma anrufen hilft auch.
Anrufen. Deutschland muss sterben ist ein wunderschöner Übergang zu unserem nächsten Thema.
Oh weia.
Eine Internetseite wurde verboten,
Internetseite verboten. So, interessant, wie kann man das denn machen, ne? Ähm wie verbietet man denn eine Internetseite? Ähm,
das Maisier bekannt. So, ich habe da Internetseite jetzt verboten, fertig. Und es handelte sich um die Internetseite links unten Punkt Indimedia,
Punkt DE wahrscheinlich oder DE Punkt org oder was auch immer. Ähm also quasi eine Unterseite von Indimedia.
Die relativ lange schon bestand als zweitausendneun wurde die gegründet und,
war,
Glaube ich, ich glaube, die hießen links unten, weil äh weil es Süddeutschland war. Ja, irgendwie äh das war jetzt auch in Freiburg oder so, wo die Leute verhaftet wurden,
Und die hat sich aber dann irgendwie ähm in über die Jahre zu so einer der wichtigsten äh Webseiten der linken Szene äh,
gemausert, ja? Also ich hab's ja ein Demonstrationsaufrufe ähm Bekennerschreiben tatsächlich bei irgendwelchen politischen Aktionen oder auch äh ja irgendwelchen äh kriminellen Aktionen.
Irgendwelche Untersuchungen über über äh zum Beispiel den NSU, ja, rechtsradikale Szene, ne, wo man irgendwie quasi Strukturen untersucht und aufgedeckt hat, ähm das auch gerne mal.
Also, wenn da irgendwie so ein so ein Nazi äh Server aufgemacht wurde, dann sind die Daten gerne mal bei links unten gelandet oder so. Also schon ähm.
Aber auch viel für Rüstzeug, was da.
War durchaus echt viel wirres Zeug dabei, ja? Ähm unter anderem auch immer mal wieder äh menschenverachtende äh Postings, in denen äh Gewalt gegen Menschen verherrlicht wurde.
So eine halt einfach, wie das so ist in dieser linken Szene. Es gab da irgendwie, gab da eine eine Reihe an Aktivitäten unterschiedlicher
Art und Form. Äh zuletzt war glaube ich wunder, glaube ich, diese äh Chatprotokolle der AfD in Sachsen-Anhalt veröffentlicht, die ja dann auch mediale Furore gemacht haben. Also, wir reden hier von
der ähm Webseite der radikalen Linken in Deutschland, wobei radikal jetzt hier inhaltlich und nicht unbedingt,
quasi was die Maßnahme angeht gemeint ist, ne? Also es waren bei weitem nicht alles,
irgendwelche Gewalttäter oder so.
Und jetzt das interessant ist, wie haben sie es denn geschafft, diese Seite äh zu zu schließen, ne? Üblicherweise ähm.
Unterhältst du so eine Seite, ich meine der Server kostet ja nicht viel, ne? Da sitzen ein paar Leute zusammen und die sind dann das Administratorenteam und die administrieren diese Seite, ne? Das Ding wird irgendwie mit Spenden oder mit eigenem Geld finanziert und da sitzt ja jetzt nicht einer und hat die
Links unten GmbH, ne? Äh und die Links unten ähm.
GmbH oder so, ähm sondern das Ding wird halt von Leuten in ihrer Freizeit betrieben.
Und äh das Innenministerium hat die dann spontan zu einem äh zu einem Verein.
Gemacht und hat diesen Verein verboten. Die haben sich also auf,
Paragraph drei, Absatz eins, Satz eins, Alternative eins und zwei des Vereinsgesetzes und haben gesagt, das ist hier ein Verein,
äh Zweck und Tätigkeiten von äh links unten liefen den Strafgesetzen zuwider und richteten sich gegen die verfassungsgemäße Ordnung und damit wurde dieser,
Verein verboten, den es aber nicht gibt. Es gab ja jetzt nicht den Links unten äh.
Aber wie kann man jetzt.
Vor allem dafür bräuchte man, dafür bräuchte man sieben Leute und ich glaube, die haben nur drei verhaftet. Also wenn du einen Verein gründest, aber lassen wir das, ne? Ja, haben die einfach spontan gemacht.
Das werden jetzt Anwälte äh klären, weil das natürlich ein, also ich halte das für ähm nicht.
Also nicht juristisch.
Aber reicht ja auch, es geht ja nur um Wahlkampf und dann kann man danach wieder zurückrudern.
Es geht ja nur darum vom G zwanzig Härte zu zeigen, gegen die Linken im Internet, ne? Als nächstes schnappt nämlich, ne, welcher linke Szene DE habe. Die linke Szene wird auch irgendwann verboten.
Bloß einfach zum Verein erklärt. Hiermit erkläre ich dich zum Linus Neumann Verein.
Ja. Hiermit erkläre ich dich zur Videos. Pass auf, dass du nicht mit der vor allem auch mal zwei Leut.
Ich bin da nicht, ich gehöre da nicht dazu. Ich habe damit nichts zu tun.
Sieben Freunde sollt ihr sein.
Genau. Ich mache mittlere Szene äh Punkt DE auf. Bin voll in der Mitte.
Ein Ärger.
Tja, dann haben sie ähm aber wie, wie sowas so läuft, ne? Ähm Reporter ohne Grenzen, denn dann war ein großes Gewesen ähm und dann haben sie nämlich gesagt, sie haben also mehrere,
Objekte in Freiburg durchsucht, wenn ich das jetzt richtig entsinne, diese ganze Geschichte ist ja schon etwas her. Ähm,
Meines äh Wohnungen und dann irgendwie so ein so eine äh autonomes Zentrum oder sowas in Freiburg oder Umgebung.
Und ein großes Thema, dabei wurden Waffen gefund,
Das ist auch immer so ein Klassiker, ja. Ähm du hast dann,
Also wenn linke Häuser durchsucht werden dann gibt's immer Waffenfunde, ne?
Die wollten, wollten halt und dann und dann findest du irgendwie nachher zwei, zwei Tage später, stellt sich dann raus. Ja, die hatten äh eine eine Palette Backsteine
im Keller, weil sie gerade das Bad oben neu gebaut haben, ne? Oder die hatten äh ein paar Weinflaschen im Keller
weil sie am Abend vorher äh Wein getrunken haben und die Polizei sagt, na ja, äh die wollten bestimmt äh Molotovcocktails bauen oder so, ne? Also mit diesen Waffenfunden muss man immer,
vorsichtig sein, so auch hier.
Denn das äh BMI stellt dann wenige Tage später klar, der Innenminister habe die Waffenpfunde nicht in den Mittelpunkt gestellt und auch nicht gesagt, dass diese unmittelbar bei den mutmaßlichen Betreibern gefunden worden wären. Ähm,
Bei den Durchsuchungen wurden neben Laptops und der IT-Technik, um dieses Jahr im Wesentlichen gegen auch gefunden. Mess, Messer, Schlagstöcke, Rohre, Zwillen, Teleskopschlagstöcke, Butterfly Messer,
Ähm für die unzutreffende Berichterstattung dritter gemeint äh ist hier dann die deutsche Presseagentur übernimmt das Ministerium keine Verantwortung. Ne? Also es ist ungefähr so ähm heute war ich bei Tim,
Und danach war ich noch woanders und ich habe Waffen sichergestellt, ne? Und alle würden natürlich sagen oder sowas wie bevor ich zur Arbeit ging, war ich bei Tim,
und habe Waffen sichergestellt,
Ja, dann würde jeder sagen, du hast bei Tim die Waffen sichergestellt. Vielleicht aber ich könnte nachher sagen, nein, ich habe auch, ganz woanders. Äh das war was anderes heute, habe ich auch gemacht, ne? Herr Bauer und Islamisten verhaftet, ne. Ähm,
Und wenn das dann falsch berichtet wird, dann bin ich da nicht dran Schuld. Also so läuft das äh so so läuft sowas regelmäßig. Es gibt jetzt also äh eine Klage vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht.
Die sich einerseits gegen die Feststellung richten, dass links unten in die Media ein Verein sei, der vereinsrichtig verboten werden könne und andererseits gegen ähm,
Die Zuordnung der Klägerinnen und Kläger zu diesem Verein
äh Zitat aus den uns bislang vorliegenden Unterlagen ist nicht ersichtlich, wie das Bundesinnenministerium die Einordnung von links unten in die Media Punkt org als Verein belegen will, geschweige denn, was die Betroffenen
der Untersuchung damit zu tun haben sollen, so Rechtsanwalt Sven Adam, der einen der Kläger vertritt.
Tja, also natürlich links unten Punkt Indimedia Punkt org war die Domain. Äh sowas macht man natürlich auf einer,
Weil du auf einer Diät im Moment keine hohes Privacy kriegst und du hast natürlich keinen Bock, dass äh jeden Tag einen kleinen Bus aus Finsterwalde zu dir nach Hause fährt.
Ja, vor allem ist die ganze Nummer ja auch insofern
absolut kontraproduktiv, also ich meine, wofür ist produktiv ist, haben wir bereits betont, ne, für die öffentliche äh Wirkung, mit da tut ja mal jemand was gegen die äh böse linke äh Gefahr
so, wobei ich halt so ein bisschen bezweifle, ob das nun wirklich am Ende auch so hilfreich ist, diese Botschaft, weil erstens äh hat man natürlich diesen Verstärkungseffekt mit
Na ja, wir wir
Wir machen jetzt mal hier so das, was auch die AfD äh äh gerne möchte, so, aber damit äh beschlagt man quasi Wähler ja eigentlich nur da drin, irgendwie das Original zu wählen, ne? Weil das ja offensichtlich schon mal die richtige Forderung war und jetzt hat dann auch mal
die Bundesregierung gemacht, um sich da irgendwie anzupassen.
Ich finde das auch krass, dass also dass die sich sogar dazu hin, dass ich sogar dazu verleiten lassen, hier eine so ein, so ein, so ein Rechtsjuristischen Hütchenspielertrick zu machen.
Das ist wirklich mega krass und vor allem es ist halt auch noch äh für ihre eigentliche Arbeit und ihre eigentlichen Ziele ja total kontraproduktiv, weil wo bitte kriegen denn äh die Behörden, denn diese Informationen denn von dieser Szene überhaupt her?
Das Ding ist doch einfach ein Füllhorn an Einblick in diese diese Szeneaktivität, die sich ja ansonsten in irgendeinem äh
Untergrund abspielt, wo sie ja dann nach eigener Aussage Probleme haben, um die Kommunikation mitzuschneiden, dann kommt da mal irgendwas im Klartext äh ins Netz gegossen und dann äh machen sie sich halt einfach das,
bin mir sicher, dass irgendwie auf der zweiten und dritten äh Arbeitsebene, weil Geheimdiensten,
et cetera, die einfach die Hände äh übern Kopf zusammengeschlagen haben und gesagt haben, sah, habt ihr sie noch alle.
Ja auf jeden Fall, also ich meine, das Ding war ja.
Abteilungsleiter und sagt so, ja, nee, warte mal, wo die Wahl ist ja gleich vorbei und so weiter, gibt bald wieder online. Es äh.
Es ist halt noch, also es ist ja ist einfach nur dumm, ne? Von vorne bis hinten dumm.
Drum halt,
ja schon, ne? Also irgendein Kalkül steckt dahinter, ob das äh für uns alle äh am Ende da richtig aufgeht. Ich habe da meine Zweifel dran. Und das enttäuscht mich auch ehrlich gesagt sehr, ne. Also ich hätte,
tatsächlich noch nicht mal erwartet, dass die CDU so eine Aufriss mach.
Ich dachte, dass sie wirklich mit ihrer äh uns geht es gut, so soll es bleiben äh Arentmetik und äh der lächelnden äh Kanzlerin äh da einfach geradeaus marschieren und äh,
aber ja offenbar ist dem nicht so und dass die SPD da halt in Form von Herrn Scholz sich da auch noch so äh hat instrumentalisieren lassen, haben wir auch schon ausführlich diskutiert. Es ist wirklich äh beunruhigend.
So dann wäre jetzt der Punkt, wo wir einfach mal generell das Vorgehen eine Seite offline zu nehmen ähm behandeln müssten, ne? Also wenn du.
Du hast du hast ja gerade schon das Beispiel gebracht für die Ermittlungsbehörden, wird das negativ sein, weil eigentlich gab's nur,
zwei Arten von Leuten, die links unten gelesen haben, entweder die Linken oder die Verfassungsschützer und Strafverfolger, die übrigens auch teilweise da Informationen bekommen haben, mit denen sie nachher irgendwelche rechten Attentäter
äh festgenommen haben, ne? So war das nicht. Ähm.
Wenn's mal wirklich nicht mehr anders ging, ne, wenn schon auf links unten stand, wär's war, dann wussten sie auch. Ähm.
Der andere Punkt ist.
Hat die Seite irgendetwas wirklich illegales getan, ja? Also klar, es gibt dieser, also der Aufruf zu Straftaten wird ist illegal, wenn ich's jetzt richtig erinnere in Deutschland,
Aber so ein Bekennerschreiben ist ja nicht verboten.
Ähm insofern schon schwierig, da eine Argumentation herbeizuführen. Äh warum diese Seite ähm.
Vor allem die gesamte Seite offline gehen muss, ne? Wenn du sagst, okay, keine Ahnung, hier ist ein Inhalt, ihr ruft dazu auf, ihr ruft hier zu Gewalt auf oder zu zu Straftaten. Das geht so nicht. Ja, ich meine, ähm vielleicht muss man dazu noch sagen, das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig. Diese Seite war bestand größtenteils als User Generator Content
Das heißt, die Leute, die da jetzt verhaftet wurden, die haben das nicht geschrieben. Das ist eine Seite, kriegt klickst den Account, kannst du was veröffentlichen. So und die eine, die an.
Anonym halt.
Weitgehend anonym ohne Loks, äh wenn sie klug fahren.
Und ähm dann äh kann da im Prinzip jeder, das war der Gedanke von Indimedia, also independent Media, äh jeder kann da was schreiben, da hast du auch irgendwie regelmäßig keine Ahnung, eine kleine Demo irgendwo stattfindet äh und dann haben die da ihren Demo-Bericht geschrieben,
damit damit man Bescheid wusst, dann sich darüber ausgetauscht so.
Umso schwieriger ist es da natürlich die Nutzer, den Betreiber der Seite äh,
Schuld nachzuweisen oder den in irgendeiner Form in die Mangel zu nehmen. Da bräuchte man schon so ein Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz für.
Ihr seht wohin die Reise geht. So jetzt aber was sagen wir grundsätzlich zu der Maßnahme, eine Webseite zu verbieten und offline zu nehmen.
Ja, schwierig. Ist ja nicht so eine Zensur findet stattmäßig.
Also ich finde, dass bei links unten völlig daneben.
Es gibt, man sieht auch einfach, dass es nicht zielführend ist. Ich würde, wenn es, ich meine, wenn wenigstens ein Beispiel angebracht würde, dass dieses Verbot in irgendeiner Form.
Einen Effekt hat, ja,
Sei es einer, den ich gut finde oder nicht, dann wäre man ja, wäre ich ja wenigstens noch zu einer Debatte bereit, aber hier ist ja noch, also hier ein Effekt wird nicht stattfinden. Ein Effekt ist ausgeschlossen, ja? Das einzige, was sie passieren, was jetzt passiert ist, die ziehen woanders hin und sind echt mächtig sauer.
Und werden sehr viel unversöhnlicher sein. Wenn das nächste Mal Olaf Scholz einen Hafengeburtstag feiert.
Insofern ist damit niemandem geholfen. Ähm und genau, also allein aus deren, aus dieser Begründung schon, äh sollte man das nicht tun, andererseits bin ich persönlich, hm, ohnehin.
Auch bei krasseren Inhalten dafür, dass wir sie nicht verstecken oder wegzensieren, sondern dass wir auf eine Gesellschaft hoffen, die diesen Mist erkennt,
die sich von die falsche Inhalte von richtigen unterscheiden kann. Diese Bevormundung führt nur in eine
Mit eine weniger mündige und weniger intelligente Gesellschaft. Und da muss man natürlich äh da also deswegen glaube ich, dass es grundsätzlich falsch ist, ja.
Wie sieht das aber aus, wenn man genau das Gleiche ähm mit einer rechten Seite macht, Tim.
Und dann noch nicht einmal mit irgendwie rechtlicher Verfügung, sondern ganz einfach als Unternehmen privat.
Ja, da gab's einen äh Fall nun in ähm den USA,
Und zwar dreht sich es hier äh um eine Aktivität der Firma Cloud Lern. Ähm wem Cloud Flair,
noch nicht so ganz bekannt ist, da muss man vielleicht mal erstmal ein bisschen äh Kontext bieten. Also Cloud Flair ist so eine Bude, die bietet so
Hontent Delivery, Networks an, also verschiedene äh Dienstleistungen im Internet für andere Webseiten, die äh Dinge tun, die man ähm,
ab einer bestimmten Größe wahrscheinlich auch tun sollte, wo man aber es irgendwie ein bisschen lästig findet, das alles selber zu machen, weil da gehört ja auch eine gewisse Expertise dazu.
Delivery ist so äh eine der Sachen ähm ein Ding, wofür Cloud Flair insbesondere bekannt ist, ist die Detox-Verteidigung, also
technische Maßnahmen, um so verteilte Attacken auf Webseiten, die ja dann immer mal wieder gerne stattfinden, um unsere Webseite down zu kriegen, ähm
genommen werden. Äh solche technischen Vorrichtungen ist bei, sind bei Cloud Flair dabei, dafür sind sie auch besonders bekannt,
und ein Distribute-DNS, das kann ich gerade nicht so gut erklären, das kannst du das äh.
Du hast dann halt keine keinen zentralen äh also deine du hast nicht nur nur einen.
Nicht nur einden ist, aber.
Verwaltenden autoritären, autoritativen Server, sondern einfach mehrere davon.
Okay, also sozusagen auch an der Stelle quasi weniger Angriffsfläche äh für solche Fälle, ne
Und ja, tatsächlich nutzt ein Großteil der populären Websites, die man so kennt, diesen Dienst, ja, nach eigenen Angaben ähm handelt äh Cloud-Flair ungefähr zehn Prozent der Verbindungen im Internet derzeit,
Also wohlgemerkt nicht, dass das Traffics, sondern zehn Prozent der Rick Fest. Wenn ihr also irgendwo auf irgendeine halbwegs populäre Webseite klickt,
Da ist sie Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieser Requisit tatsächlich erstmal durch irgendeinen Server von Cloudfahrt durch äh marschiert, bevor er zu der anderen Webseite durchgeleitet wird, äh relativ hoch,
Und damit ist halt Cloud für eine der größten und natürlich äh auch zunehmend wichtigen Infrastrukturen in diesem äh Internet.
Kurz der, also der Grund, warum man das macht.
Ja, um einfach dann automatisch eben diese Dienste zu erhalten. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt besonders Dedos gefährdet ist und das ist man halt zwangsläufig in dem Moment, wo man äh da ein Store
ja, dann Store drauf hat, man verkauft halt Dinge, man lebt davon, dass das Ding auf vierundzwanzig sieben online ist. So und jetzt kommt halt irgend so eine Bude
die findet das ungeil, möchte ihr einen eigenen Store pushen und kauft sich dann äh äh irgendwo in windigen Ländern da mal so eine Dedos Truppe zusammen mit hier zehntausend Dollar. Wir machen den platt für so und so lange
Gibt's alles und dann äh findet es halt einfach mal statt und Cloud Flair
hat halt technische Maßnahmen, mit dem sie das äh verhindern, wie die genau funktionieren, kann ich wenig zu sagen, aber.
Expertise darin so dir das abzuwehren
und natürlich auch einfach mal eine ganz andere Verfügbarkeitsstrategie, ne? Die können dann
die die surfen die Request ja nicht an einem Server, sondern immer am nächsten zu dir. Ist halt ein Content Distribution Network, was hier primär einfach als al
äh dann auf Cashing schaltet, ne? Die hängen hängen in der Regel dazwischen zwischen dir und dem und deinem deinem Requester und ähm,
Ja, jetzt haben sie halt, wenn wenn es dann darum geht, dann dann sind's machen sie das die Mittegation für dich locker, mal eben so.
Genau, also ähm jetzt ist Cloud schwer nach eigenen Angaben offen für alle
Das heißt, sie bewerten jetzt nicht, äh was du da auf deiner Webseite machst und tust und treibst so. Ähm,
Sind auch schon so äh Hacker äh Gruppen, wie zum Beispiel Lalzeck sind ähm nachdem sie selber solchen Detox-Attacken ausgesetzt waren, dort äh hingezogen, ich weiß nicht, kannst du zu Leitsecken bisschen was sagen, wir sind die Hintergründe, nur so.
Die die haben irgendwie FBI und so auseinandergenommen ähm Stratt vor und die haben immer Sachen geleakt.
Ich habe auch selber so Dedos-Attacken, glaube ich, auch.
Nee, die haben eher einfach äh also tatsächlich irgendwie FBI, Stratvor und andere Unternehmen aus diesem, also aus dem
innere Sicherheitsbereich gehackt und die Sachen einfach immer nur auf die einfach immer geliegt, auf Pace bin oder irgendwie,
Sachen, ja? Ähm, die wurden nachher auch kamen aus diesem Enonimes-Umfeld.
CIA haben sie sich haben sie äh.
CIA, die haben sich mit allen, die haben sich mit allen angelegt und dann irgendwann äh hatten hat das FBI glaube ich einen von denen infiltriert. Dann haben sie die alle, sind alle eingewandert.
Sind jetzt auch durchaus eine eine streitbare äh Gruppe, ja? Also jetzt nicht irgendwie klar äh unbedingt jetzt immer so aus dieser
äh Head Fraktion erkennbar, aber das war dann Cloud-Flair halt eigentlich egal, ne? Es gab da natürlich auch Proteste dagegen hier, warum äh,
die haben, Wiki Leaks ist bei Cloud Flair untergekommen und Cloud Flair hat halt immer gesagt so na ja
wenn wir da anfangen irgendwie zu unterscheiden, dann kommen wir da in Teufelsküche, ne, sodass dann halt auch irgendwelche anderen äh Gruppen, die denen dann wiederum von dritten, terroristischen Propaganda nachgesagt wurde, dorthin kamen und Cloud Flair ist halt eigentlich immer mit dem
Hinweis auf Informationsfreiheit gekommen und hat gesagt, ne, wir dulden das jetzt einfach ja, wir haben hier auch den den Bundestag Punkt DE.
Machen auch nicht immer alles richtig.
So
Nun kam zuletzt auch eine Webseite namens The Daily Stormer, also ne, der tägliche Stürmer, man sieht schon die äh Avancen hier ins rechte Umfeld. Äh bei Cloud Flair äh unter. Das ist so eine,
total weit rechts gelagerte Hetzer Webseite anders kann man das glaube ich nicht
ne, die jetzt also insbesondere in der Diskussion um diese Nazi-Demo in äh Charleson äh nochmal zur Öffentlichkeit äh äh kam.
Und äh ja auch da haben sozusagen sich die äh die Nazis quasi bei bei Cloudfair äh Schutz versprochen. Und.
Da werden sie wahrscheinlich auch geblieben, wenn,
Sieh nicht so ein bisschen den Fehler äh gemacht hätten äh in ihrer eigenen Kommunikation zu sagen äh ja,
wir sind ja hier bei Cloud Flair unter äh gekommen, die beschützen uns, weil äh,
Weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie die Formulierung war, aber so nach dem Motto die finden's ja sozusagen auch gut oder die sind ja sozusagen auf unserer Seite oder so.
Das ist dann so der Punkt gewesen, wo dann sogar bei Cloud Flair äh dann die letzte Sicherung äh rausgesprungen ist. Und in der Folge,
Nachdem auch schon vorher Google und Gode die diverse Dienste für Daily Stormer eingestellt haben. Ähm haben ja halt gesagt, nee, Leute, echt, aber,
Wir schmeißen euch jetzt hier mal raus. Und das ist dann sozusagen das erste Mal, dass das bei Cloud Flair äh nach dieser langen Geschichte von, ist uns egal, wer bei uns äh unterkommt. Ähm das erste Mal, dass sie das dann halt auch wirklich getan haben.
Ne? Genau und zwar halt nicht die Tatsache, dass es eine Nazi-Webseite war, die sie zu diesem Entschluss ähm geführt hat, sondern schlicht und ergreifend, dass die Administratoren deshalb behaupteten Cloud-Flair, würde sie halt beschützen. Und das war dann sozusagen ähm.
Das sind einfach äh,
Gibt's ein schönes Zitat? My Rasion Day for making this destision boy simple, the people behind daily Stormer Airshores in der Heady Nove
So, schreibt halt äh Prinz, der äh Chef von Cloud fährt, ne. This was and about cherry desision. Und was ist eigentlich äh extrem bemerkenswert ist,
Ist wie Cloud Flair jetzt dann hier auch gleich mit dieser Entscheidung an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist, weil sie natürlich auch selber gesehen haben, dass das quasi für sie dann ein First ist, der in gewisser Hinsicht äh dem, wie sie sich bisher verhalten haben, äh widerspricht.
Und dann gibt's halt einen äh längeren äh Blogpost, Vivary Terminated, Daily Stormer auf ihrem eigenen Blog,
wo er halt ausführlich erstmal die äh Beweggründe darlegt, warum es überhaupt dazu äh gekommen ist. Aber noch sehr viel ausführlicher, äh eine eine Grundsatzdebatte aufmacht.
Zum Thema Zensur, weil sie halt sozusagen von ihrer eigenen Entscheidung gesagt haben,
Unsere Entscheidung ist halt jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, weil wir eigentlich etwas tun, was wir gar nicht tun wollen,
Wir sehen uns jetzt hier quasi in der Rolle ähm in der wir eigentlich gar nicht sein wollen.
Und das ist dann ein sehr analytischer Blogpost, allein schon deshalb mal sehr interessant, sich den mal genauer anzuschauen, weil er dann erstmal so eine ganze Reihe von typischen Infrastrukturelementen des aktuellen Internets aufzählt, äh die heutzutage das Netz eben ausmachen, ne? Also
Neben den eigentlichen Inhaltsanbietern natürlich so Plattformen wie Facebook
Hoster, die Server haben Transitprovider, die halt jetzt die große Backend-Infrastruktur machen, so Level drei, et cetera äh Reverse,
konnte delivere Networks wie Akamai oder eben auch Cloud-Flair selber
DNS ähm Provider natürlich dann diese Registrats, Registriers aus der ganzen DNS äh Geschichte, die eigentlich einen Internetservice-Provider
andere äh DNS Provider und natürlich irgendwie Browser,
Äh Serge Engines et cetera, die ecant. Also er führt das sozusagen alles mal auf, um einfach auch mal zu sagen, so äh man könnte jetzt eigentlich an jeder dieser Stellen irgendwie hergehen und mit Zensurmaßnahmen kommen
Und äh es ist aber einfach eine allgemeine Debatte darüber nötig, wer eigentlich
so 'ne Entscheidung enttreffen darf und auf welcher Basis treffen darf um dann sozusagen,
Inhalte dann vielleicht wirklich mal einzuschränken in dem Moment, wo sie halt einfach äh.
Nicht tragbar sind von der Gesellschaft, ne? Nur als Firma möchte er diese Entscheidung halt einfach nicht machen. Sie haben diese Entscheidung jetzt deshalb gefällt,
weil sie quasi von diesen Nazis äh inselbe Boot gezogen werden sollten.
Ja interessant finde ich hier seine äh sein Abseits Freedom of Speach ähm und du Process?
Ähm,
Und ich glaube, das Zeichen dazwischen ist, dass ist Lesser Ben. Also er sagt, du Process ist wichtiger als Meinungsfreiheit. Äh du Process heißt also quasi, dass man einen geriegelten,
dass man einen geregelten rechtlichen Rahmen hat, in dem verfahren wird und in dem immer gleich verfahren wird. Und da sagt er, na ja, er wäre natürlich ein sehr.
Sehr würde Meinungsfreiheit sehr hoch hängen als äh Nordamerikaner, aber wahrscheinlich gäbe es äh andere Staaten, in denen das nicht so ist, aber der Wert, den alle hochhalten, wäre also quasi diese,
Du Process, der geregelte Ablauf, ja? Und dann argumentiert er ähm,
Es sollte quasi eine politische Legitimität und Vorhersagbarkeit geben äh für Entscheidungen welcher
Welche Inhalte wie eingeschränkt werden und Firmen sollten dies nicht tun. Was ich sehr interessant finde, weil die quasi sagen, wir haben die jetzt rausgekickt und wir hätten es nicht tun sollen. Und dann sagt man, glaube ich, ich konnte das machen, weil ich der CEO bin und das sollte eigentlich nicht,
sollte eigentlich nicht sein, dass ich das kann.
Ja
Andererseits diese Meinungsfreiheit oder Redefreiheit, Debatte wird ja auch häufig so interpretiert, dass Unternehmen sich entscheiden, also quasi ihre Meinungsfreiheit wahrnehmen, wenn sie die Geschäftsbeziehung zu jemandem
unterbrechen. Und das ist ja an dieser Stelle.
Auch der Fall, ne? Ich meine, durch man also die andere Argumentation wäre ja nun, also Cloud Flair kann sich ja jeden Geschäftspartner selber aussuchen,
Und wenn sie einen bestimmten Geschäftspartner nicht haben möchten, dann sind sie jetzt nicht unbedingt verpflichtet dem Dienstleistungen zu erbringen.
Genau, man ist nicht verpflichtet, man kann das halt einfach sein lassen, wobei die äh Redefreiheit der Unternehmen ja nicht selten dann auch mit dem Urheberrecht durchgesetzt wird,
ja anderes Thema.
So, ich merke, wir sind beide ein bisschen durch.
Wir sind schon äh bisschen durch, aber das ist äh auf jeden Fall ein bemerkenswerter ähm Fall. Ja, ich finde das äh eigentlich auch mal sehr interessant, weil ähm
Hier können sich glaube ich eine ganze Menge beteiligt äh das äh äh in Digitalien mal eine Scheibe abschneiden, wie man öffentliche Kommunikation macht. Ja und wie man eben auch zu seinen
Entscheidung steht, so ein Verhalten würde ich mir mal wie bei der Telekom und anderen entsprechenden Plänen mal wünschen, ja, dass man sozusagen da nicht immer nur so duckmäuserisch da irgendwie mal mitgeht, mal nicht, sondern dass man äh auch äh Stellung bezieht und auch mal die die erforderliche
politische Debatte äh in dem Moment einfach auch mal anruft. Die halt so in dem Fall äh selten stattfindet. Ja.
Aber auch hier na mein Körper braucht jetzt nicht, sich hinzusetzen, sozusagen, ah toll, jetzt gibt's weniger Nazis, für deren Mythenbildung ist es doch nur äh auch wiederum zuträglich, ne? Also sie sagen dann, ja hier, der der
seht ihr die Meinungsdiktatur, dass es kein freies Land mehr, wir müssen hier einen Befreiungskrieg führen oder so, ich meine, sind doch dann auch die Verschwörungstheorien und.
Ja, ist auch bemerkenswert, dass der Daily Store jetzt halt irgendwie in Russland untergekommen ist.
Ein Shadow, der Böses dabei denkt.
So und das bringt uns jetzt zu den Terminen.
Ja und so viel äh haben wir da eigentlich auch gar nicht und wir fangen quasi in House an, denn der erste Termin des Pistolinos. Du bist in äh Frankfurt im Gespräch zum Thema das Internet
als äh Kriegsschauplatz. Das Ganze äh bei der politischen Gesellschaft Frankfurt
am Main, am neunzehnten neunten zwanzig siebzehn um neunzehn Uhr fünf Vortragssaal der Frankfurter Sparkasse
neue Mainzer Straße und äh ja, ich schätze mal, du wirst da viel über Krieg und Frieden äh reden. Wie ist so deine Art ist.
Ey, ich bin einfach nur selten in Frankfurt und ich habe gedacht, da bietet sich doch mal die Gelegenheit. Ähm ja.
Ähm, noch ein paar Lacköre dazu zu holen.
Am vierundzwanzigsten neunten findet in
bundesweit die Bundestagswahl statt. Mehrere Parteien geben sich da die Blöße, unter anderem CDU,
SPD, aber auch
Linke, grüne AfD und sogar die totgeglaubte FDP sind wieder im Rennen. Das Ergebnis gibt's dann um achtzehn oder zwanzig Uhr oder so irgendwie auf den,
im öffentlich öffentlich-rechtlichen Lügenfernsehen.
Und die Partei nicht zu vergessen.
Die Partei, die Partei hat immer Recht.
Genau, die hat recht. Mal gucken, äh wie sie abschneidet. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ja und last but not least äh auch darauf möchte ich hinweisen in eigener Sache. Äh vom siebenundzwanzigsten bis neunundzwanzigsten
zehnten findet in München die Subscribe statt, die Subscribe neun, das ist ja unsere eigentlich halbjährliche
Konferenz und Workshopserie äh die muss ja leider jetzt im Frühjahr ausfallen, deswegen haben wir ja das erste Mal wieder Subscribe und da sich eine ganze Menge getut in Podcast land und wir das auch umfangreich äh zu thematisieren vorhaben,
für jeden, den sozusagen das
Casting am Herz liegt, insbesondere natürlich Podcasts, aber nicht nur auch Entwicklern oder eben auch besonders interessierten Hörern, die Subscribe durchaus,
gefallen können, denke ich. Ja, auf Subscribe Punkt DE findet ihr da alle Informationen dazu.
Beim hessischen Rundfunk.
Beim bayrischen Rundfunk war beim bayerischen Rundfunk sind wir. Genau, ja sehr nett äh muss man sagen. Also der äh bayerische äh Rundfunk ähm,
Gefallen gefunden an unserem Treiben und stellt uns da kostenlos die Konferenzsäle zur Verfügung. Von daher haben wir da beste Voraussetzungen sind da im großen Rundfunkratssaal
untergebracht und den Anliegenden Räumen. Wir haben vor allem extrem viel Platz, sehr viele kleinere Räume, die alle auch nochmal so als Meetingräume ausgelegt sind
Das heißt, man kann da auch prima seine eigenen Workshops machen, wenn man da eine gute Idee hat, setzt man die einfach um einen Zettel und äh los geht's und ja, gutes Essen und Spaß und,
tolle Podcasts jetzt mal gucken.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie die Podcaster alle versammelt am äh am Sitzungstisch des Rundfunkrats sitzen und so am.
Zukunft entscheiden.
Wie das wie der Podcast aus der Nische kommt.
Genau.
Spiegel online.
Der der Feind stößt vor über die Surfer aus Russland.
Ähm da können wir uns ja euer über Podcasting generell können wir uns auch nochmal eben unterhalten, aber heute nicht mehr, ey, meine Stimme ist durch.
Tja, Mensch, ich habe jetzt auch irgendwie zehn Stunden Podcast Material in vierundzwanzig Stunden zusammen aufgenommen. Jetzt auch erstmal gut.
Ah äh das war übrigens ähm.
Ich hatte in der letzten Sendung mit Thomas Herr mal gefragt, wann äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik gehört wird. Also wie das ist aber net, okay, wir haben jetzt falls irgendwie vielleicht so zehn, zwanzig Antworten. Ähm.
Würde schätzen gefühlt.
Relativ bald nach der nach der Veröffentlichung, also einige haben sogar gesagt, dass sie andere Podcasts unterbrechen. Das ist übrigens nicht mein Anspruch. Könnte es ruhig.
Breaking News sozusagen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Schalten.
Logbuch in Berlin, Logbuch in Berlin und Manni Breukmann schaltet direkt rüber in einem Fußball.
Ähm.
Die für deutsche Podcast Konferenz äh Schaltung sozusagen.
Aber es waren auch einige dabei, die es aus München.
Ein neues Release aus München.
Da kommt erstmal Werbung.
Ein Moment in Köln.
Na ja ähm.
Genau, wird, wird relativ zeitnah gehört. Wir sehen ja, also die Downloadstatistiken sind natürlich schon so, dass innerhalb von,
vierundzwanzig Stunden neunzig Prozent der Downloads erfolgt sind.
Das heißt die meisten von dass das interpretiere ich als dass die meisten Leute viele Podcasts hören, ne? Dass der Podcast Client schön seine Abonnements brav abholt,
Und äh dann liegen sie im Flash auf dem iPhone Südkreuz und äh warten auf Warten, dass der Bluthöfferführer verbunden wird, damit man nur was kann.
Oh Mann, du bist schon wirklich durch. Ähm.
Ich danke an dieser Stelle oder möchtest du auch noch was sagen Tim.
Ähm.
Nee, ne? Komm, ist gut jetzt.
Ich habe nicht mehr viel zu sagen.
Wann hörst du, wann hörst du denn Logbuch? Ah, ich kriege.
Die ganze Nacht.
Der du schläfst.
Echo kriege ich nicht bloß meinem Kopf.
Ich auch manchmal.
So denn, wir freuen uns. Das ist die Sendung vorbei ist, ihr hoffentlich auch.
Und ich danke kurz Hannes, Thomas, Andreas Simon, Hano und einer unbekannten Person, die ich jetzt einfach mal Lady nenne, ähm kann sich ja vielleicht nochmal bei mir melden.
Bitte melde dich. Und ihr schaltet wieder ein, wenn es heißt ein Logbuch, jetzt Politik, bis bald, tschüss.
Ciao ciao.